I don't know why it's not capturing the desktop audio.
I think it might catch now.
Okay.
Let's go.
All right, it's been my PC.
It's just not helping me today.
Did anyone take any damage?
I don't think so, right?
We all went red.
I thought.
No, I don't.
You said it was long yet.
Oh, yeah, I took four damage, apparently.
Five.
Yeah, you got like scratched up and Roma.
I don't know.
We're bearing it.
You won't have enough time for longer, so I'm just going to move your rage down.
Two, we're bearing it die two.
Plus two, right?
And plus 28 for your current, so that's 53.
You would have enough to short rest, but probably won't be enough for a long rest.
The amount of time between last session and now.
All right.
I'm going to move from Malfus's POV to this.
Okay, after last night's fight, Roma, you find yourself waking up choking on the water
that you're trying to spit out as Bob is trying to resuscitate you back, essentially.
Malfus, you and Bob kind of dragged him into the mansion while all this like vet for
essentially just left a bunch of mud sand and just just water pouring all through the
mansion to the room that you were signed.
Well, you are waiting.
Roma.
There we go.
Yes, sir.
You can go now.
I can go now.
Yeah, I mean, like this is the setting.
Go ahead.
What are you saying?
Oh, I wasn't saying anything.
If Bob's resuscitating me, I'm getting the kiss of death from a zombie.
So I'm going to wake up and be like, God damn, my mouth is all dirty.
And then ask him to go and get my clothes.
How far is the ship?
We weren't on the ship.
No, we were in the mansion.
Yeah, you're in the mansion.
Yeah, but you're clothes where are we going to find your clothes?
Are they in the ship?
No, they're in a back alley of town.
So you're telling me to go to a town to a random back alley to find your clothes?
Just follow the destruction for us.
My investigation score is very low.
Well, you don't need to investigate.
You're going to see destruction, brother.
Can I investigate for like a underwear or something to...
It's in the warehouse.
I mean, you would be able to find some clothes in the closet.
Yeah, we're in the mansion.
Yeah, they're like curtains.
You don't need the curtains.
There's clothes in the closets or whatever.
Yeah, but are those clothes going to fit him?
Because he's huge.
You can search for it.
Okay, I'll go and search for them.
And if not possible, then you're just going to have to wear like a toga made of curtain.
Like, you know, Greek people.
I can't do that, brother.
I can't do it.
You're a barbarian.
You're like always naked.
Sir, my pain is in there.
I don't know, you can short-rest and mouth as you can also short-rest.
It may be probably like 30 to 40 minutes have passed since the fight.
Malfa says you still like...
Since there, I don't need to short-rest.
Can I go and get his like pan back?
Yeah.
Because he needs his pan.
Malfa says you're still kind of like out of breath from like pulling him out of the
water.
You stand near the entrance of the room as you hear knock at the door.
I'll open up.
Okay.
Bob, what was your role?
What the fuck?
Why is it rolling so much?
Just supposed to be too weird.
Did you have all those band-on?
No, I turned that off because I had to just roll it.
Yeah, it said two dice.
That's fine.
12 and 11.
That's 23.
Stop back to fucking...
Full, yeah.
Jesus Christ.
But I don't think you have any head left now.
Yeah, Bob, you should be able to find like a heavy size like someone who has been working
in like...
This is basically a chef's attire with like the hat and everything with the white apron
and all of that.
I will bring them back.
From the man to the mansion.
Yeah.
I don't need...
I don't want to get like any clothes or stuff.
I want to get your pan back.
Pan?
Does Roma have his pan with him?
It would be...
He wouldn't drop the pan at any point.
He would have it on him.
Oh, it's fine.
Oh, yeah, okay, okay.
If he dropped it, it would be near the water which you can already probably have grabbed.
I'm assuming.
I'm just saying like you can't lose your player inventory whatever transformation you go
through.
You know, it is just to make things easier.
Okay.
Yeah.
All right.
As you open the door, Malfus, you see Jefferson, the butler of the house, looks at you as you
open the door and he looks at all the mud that you've dragged in.
And he just looks at you and he just sighs and disappointment and goes, "The floor is
a agony.
Do try to respect it."
I'll get him up in the morning.
Anyway.
Any able body individuals follow me.
Lord Veilhard requires you.
He turns around and he's just waiting for one of you to follow him or however many.
Okay.
As you step outside the gate, he just turns around, closes the door as he looks in before
going and he goes, "Do be careful with that outfit.
We don't want to torn up."
And please return safely once you're done.
And he closes the door and just starts walking in front of you, Malfus.
As he's moving you through the mansion downstairs in the Lord Veilhard's room, not the younger
son's room, essentially you step in and you see kind of cash in just sitting down on one
of the chairs at the table and you see Goro just making laps of the room.
As he looks at you and he goes, "Oh great, you're here.
I think you should be aware of what is going on."
He turns up like the dendin mushi that has been going off repeatedly sending the same message
over and over and what you hear will be told to you when I say, "Come back from Baptiste."
Alright.
Meanwhile.
Two hours away or something.
At least you seem to be somewhere that you're not sure where you are.
You hear a similar voice that you've known for a while as he says to you, "Finally, I have
recovered enough."
Now.
I think there's something we want to discuss.
Do we not?
We or you?
I want his freedom and you seem to deny me of any.
Tell me this boy, you hold a power most of these retis have been dined to conquer.
So I have you denied it.
Why have you not used those ranks?
You say it's a power I desire but well that most desire.
You had a chance on Desabella to be with someone who desired your power and would use it.
You know what you're doing.
Sure you do not mean the skeleton I was about to.
That man could not handle even a single sliver of my being.
But that he wanted to.
I do not.
Very well.
I suppose you will learn soon enough once you suffer the same pain I have endured for
a young man.
You will lose everything you love.
You will lose everything you ever cared for and then you will come back to me.
While these like last few phrases echo in your head you just hear Linus's voice on
the other end trying to shake you up as he goes.
Up to you.
Are you okay?
As you open your eyes and you see Linus and you are completely lying down face front
on like the deck of your ship.
Just tired is off.
The rings.
They are worsening.
Are they not?
He's trying to take control but.
Have the name of the phylum offered this long.
You do not want another incident.
I will think of something.
In the meantime try not to.
Over exert yourself.
Why are you back on the ship?
Because the convoy it may not be as easy to get driven as just get it out anymore.
Alright, fill me in.
So I'm just going to skip over the parts you will explain like everything that you were
explained back on the mansion and after that we can continue.
I see.
So what do you put on?
Well, one idea was for if JavaScript can master up the string.
We wait on the point where security is lowest and he transports you and himself into the
carriage to get drove in and you ship you guys up while we created a distraction.
But knowing that.
Droven is a developer user.
There may be countermeasures in place to stop double-free use abilities being used.
It is very likely.
It's our biggest thing to worry about mainly is distraction.
If we can secure a great distraction attacking the carriage and getting driven free should
be easier.
What all did you find out about those vials that you we got from Borough?
Yes.
Well, one of them is pretty straightforward.
It closes up any and all wounds that you've encountered within a combat or whatever.
One of them, as you saw, reverts the effects of the mix transformation.
It's in the gene mutation, whatever that is.
The white one is peculiar.
The black one is peculiar.
I still haven't been able to figure out what it does.
I would be careful.
The green one that Roma had is the one that closes up the wounds and the red one I think
is rather not to be used.
Might send anyone who uses it no frenzy.
And the frenzy?
It just makes you feel a bit light-footed, I suppose.
And you say frenzy, will they still not maintain their reasoning in that frenzy?
Probably.
Unless they are very conscious of their mind.
I have an idea of an distraction.
I got a call from Mira.
No.
She was probably not happy that you were still associated with me.
That is occupant on this ship.
Does make sense.
Since we have to get rid of Bora, at least what she's instructed me, if we take him to
the island, force him to consume that potion while he is fed him loose on the marines.
That should be a big enough distraction.
No.
It is a big gamble.
Knowing War, he is more than capable of handling.
That's you, then.
But you said if their mind is stable, they should be able to.
Yes.
There is also the matter of his vehicle.
His car only works when he is inside it.
Also for Rose Corn, use for his car any longer.
This elementary science, I should be able to figure that out.
Okay.
Give me, we'll have to take the gamble.
Give me one moment.
I'll be back.
Go check on the travels to be able to master up the street and participate in this.
Have your back.
Very well.
He leaves the room and heads out to Dravo's room as you enter in.
Can I find the Dinden machine that the common or contact me on?
Yeah, I should be right on some table in your room.
I'll pick it up and dial it.
Okay.
Can you roll a Vandy 20 for me?
Just basically 20.
Okay.
It rings for a while, but eventually someone on the other line picks up.
Is this the Commodore?
Again, an echoey grainy voice comes through, kind of like masking the real voice behind.
He just goes.
There better be a good reason you are contacting me, pirate.
If it is about your little friend, I'm sad to say your decision has been a bit too late.
Sorry, stop me.
What?
Go just done then.
It is done.
Whatever you do with a borrow will be retaliated with a tenfold even worse.
I would like to sit the Dinden machine down so we can still hear and I'm walking up for
the borrow.
Start fucking borrow.
He said it will be returned tenfold.
He did say that.
Part of me actually wants to do that now.
One D2.
No more body use.
If it is a two that is what I'm doing.
Come on two.
Come on ten.
It is a two.
Oh fuck.
Do I have to say it?
Kagashi.
No, I'm not allowing you to fuck borrow.
I'm not fucking smite all of you.
We had to calm your tets.
What are you doing?
I'm not doing anything.
I did.
I mean probably not.
It keeps it pretty close to him.
It cleans and stuff.
I would like to grab a blade and chop off the world's dick.
I mean once he starts screaming I'm going to step it in his mouth.
So shut him up.
Okay.
And I'll cauterize the wound with the fire bolt.
Is the.
I mean, you're not going to stand any longer.
I'm not going to stand any longer.
While he hears all this.
No, you only hear silence on the other side.
Simon doesn't he hung up or just the same.
It is still going.
The static from the tendon moshie is still going.
So you know that he's listening.
You know, Commodore, you say retaliation, but.
You shook first.
I'm here, but you made the first aggressive move.
So if you want to retaliate to my retaliation.
Just know I'll come back at you a thousand fold stronger.
You want your little pet back.
I'll give him back to you.
But you just know.
You'll always be my bitch like he was.
Captain Calder was.
This is.
All right.
Notting him back out.
Roll the dice.
No, no, you don't need to roll the dice.
I'm just going to move on.
I want to see if he kills them.
We're going to keep doing this over and over again.
The way.
So.
Is.
I'm going to go find minus to see if.
I'm in trouble sir.
Linus has been like carrying travel.
Drives out of the room.
While you get out of.
For your chambers.
And he looks at you and goes.
What was that about.
The Commodore.
Contact me did me before threatening someone.
With Mira giving me the ultimate.
Well, Mira getting orders.
I just needed to make sure.
Before.
And he just modified everything I needed to know.
So.
So it's dribble-sable to.
I have looked at him.
It is not really a physical.
I'm not a log that he has with more of a mental.
So I cannot help with that.
But maybe I can try to increase his range.
Only by.
A couple 20 something feet.
But that's about it.
That should work.
I'll grab four or you can get on the.
We're up up and get back to the island.
I'm on a very well.
Around the same time.
About East as soon as you start to go toward outside of the.
Below deck you go on top of the deck.
And then you get.
Then the moushi call from.
And I'm going to move back to mouth.
All right.
Malvis what you hear from the then and moushi.
Like projection from the.
Then the moushi they have placed in the room.
And then the same message that keeps saying the same thing over and over.
Attention all marine.
Commandants station at nearby.
Islands requesting backup.
This is the warship that is carrying the criminal.
We executed on news hold this evening.
We are being attacked by an unknown entity.
A flying figure.
We do not know if it is a devil fruit ability or what.
One of our warship is scorched and capsizing.
We're trying everything to hold back this unknown entity.
Requesting backup and then it loops again.
Well there you have it.
So maybe they have already speed it up the execution and they're already on their way here.
The moushi seems to be a couple of hours away from here.
It shouldn't be that far.
The only problem is whatever is attacking them seems to be very powerful.
And if they sink the warship then drove in is probably dead.
Another issue that I just found out about is one of the Marines on that warship.
One of the captains knows me personally.
And the other one also knows me kind of.
But that just makes it a bit more difficult for me to assist you on this task.
Maybe your plans will have to change.
After the message was repeating the buff is face like completely changed like this confling like.
But this sort of a mix of like hope and stuff.
We need a ship right now.
Cache in looks at you.
It's something you're not telling us.
Godless.
I would have you out of my mansion as soon as possible.
So I will tell Jefferson to prepare a ship as soon as possible.
Prepare the ship.
Get room on both on a ship that way as quickly as you can.
And I'm going to run out the door.
You run out of the door.
You see Jack kind of going back in the room as you're leaving.
And you cross each other's eyes as both of you just move on opposite directions toward.
One toward the room one away as you run up what are you doing.
I'm going to contact the peace.
Right.
You use the radio machine that Baptist left you contact him through the radio machine.
On the other side it would be Cade that answers the radio machine.
Is Baptist there?
Yeah, the captain was here.
It's probably below that.
Let me check.
He runs and as you're coming out of the below deck, you see Cade as he hands you over the enemy.
Hello.
But this she could be here.
Are you sure?
We there's a repeat that broadcast going around to fly into the attack in the worships.
I don't want to miss this chance.
So if you could turn ship that way, I'll be all mutual free.
So you all have a way to get there.
I'm going to mention this prepared a ship for Bob and Roma.
I'll instruct Cade to wait with direction.
It would be using the same channel that you stopped the other ship.
Cade, you heard him.
I kept him.
He runs back to the helm.
He starts leaving like robes tying him as he runs back to the helm and starts moving the ship.
The ship that you arrived in Baptist, the other ship, you have to get that to or do you want to just leave it behind?
It's like a little robot.
No, no, no, you took the whole ship, I think.
I did.
I think you need to take a robot.
No, I don't think you did.
Okay, okay.
It would be a small robot.
But you can't probably have that then.
Let's take a robot.
Yay.
You want to take the robot to the fight?
I think you need to take the robot to the fight.
I thought I took it alone because I would have to come back with mouth is in not mouth.
Yeah, okay.
It would be too many people.
I thought they gave it to us to go out and then.
Sure, sure, sure.
We'll just assume like there was no one you only took it to here.
Okay.
As the robot fired, as the ship starts to shake and erratically move,
you see Zim coming out of the below deck and she looks at you.
What the hell is happening now?
You might want to stay below deck.
God, man, she just heads down.
You're going to be in there.
And just fucking pop my head and get ready to leave now.
I'm gonna brush my teeth, man.
Wait a second.
You brush your teeth.
It never feels like you do.
It never feels like this is the first time you've ever been in my mouth.
Oh,
I need answers.
You'll make me draw up.
He said this is the first time you're in my mouth.
All right.
Well, this is happening.
What's your plan?
Are you going to travel through the boat?
Do you want to meet up with Baptiste first?
No, he's different.
Yeah, I'm going to meet.
I assume that this is like going there and just going to meet him off
way somewhere.
Okay.
I'll say about around this time.
You are greeted by Jefferson again, Roma and Bob.
It's mostly like a merchant ship, but this guy's like as a merchant ship,
but it's actually a whale heart vessel.
They've just taken down all the banners and everything.
So it's bare bones pretty much.
As you see behind you two of the people,
one of them you recognize as the bodyguard for Guru,
the shooter or like the sniper.
He is accompanied by another guy who is very kind of like a tango mask
and his outfit is a bit different.
And you can you guys give me a perception?
Both of you.
Yes, sir.
All right.
I think it's just a different person.
You don't know who this guy is.
As he just walks up, he greets you and goes,
well, this is the only way I could figure out that I might be able to help you.
As long as my mask stays on, no one will know.
Now onto the ship.
Fortunately, my giv will have to stay because he's pretty recognizable.
But for me and who are you again?
He takes off the tango mask and he goes,
oh, this is me.
I'm the guy that you were on the ship off.
Oh, cool mask.
Can I have that?
No.
Okay. He puts it on and he just starts walking onto the ship.
As he is for Suroma.
You know, I'm going to get that soon enough.
As he is.
Who is this dude?
Like, well, we're in a ship.
Oh, he's a dude with the dog.
Hey, can I pet your dog?
The dog.
Well, I guess we got a.
Followed mouth.
This I don't know how to run a ship.
I just got a cook.
It's fine.
I'll just go to the ship.
It's as good as halfway, at least to your ship.
And then we can continue.
Oh, we might need to take this all the way.
I don't think it's possible.
Our ship was fucked up.
I don't even know if our ship can make it.
Whatever it is, we will have to deal with it.
We don't really have any options.
Well, do you know how long it's going to be?
It's probably to get to your ship about an hour or so.
Oh, perfect.
I can whip you guys up.
What you want?
You want eggs and grits?
I am full.
Thank you.
Oh, yo, you can't turn down my food.
Cowboy dude.
Do you know how to make honey giri?
I want to giri.
Yeah.
Hell no.
All right.
We need something simple, simple, simple, simple.
It is simple.
It's a rice ball.
What do you mean?
What's more simple than that?
Perfect.
I'll make you a rice ball.
I'll wrap it up and see we and I'll put a little.
All right.
A little too long.
Okay.
I'll talk to that then.
He looks back and he just as the ship starts to leave.
He waves to cash in who is at the docks kind of sending him away.
Cash in just looks at him.
He doesn't wave back and he just turns around and just keeps walking
with inside as mentioned.
You see Jefferson looking at you Roma and he he's kind of
mouthing words and it goes like you need to return those clothes
intact.
Very well then.
It turns around and starts to leave.
Hey Jefferson.
He turns around and looks at you.
You got a chef.
And then I'm just going to walk away.
All right.
As you guys are making your way to like a intersection point
where you can probably try to figure out what's the plan once you get there.
Malthus you arrive on the ship about 30 minutes earlier than your rest of the crew.
But you have been like completely like fully dashing.
So you are probably out of sorts and you as you land on top of the mass
you slide in through the middle pole and as you drop down on your knees.
Baptiste.
You see Malthus land down.
I'll go and like help him up.
If you're going to need your energy for later.
I know.
How far out are we?
You know what the directions.
Linus at this point is kind of like putting his hands on
drove and like back as you see both of his hands like kind of face into his body
and he goes always Malthus here.
There's something wrong.
Plans changed.
Hopefully the opposite.
I see.
Where are we heading?
We're heading to the belly of the beast.
All right.
I have the serums if you want them.
You can hand them over to you.
Brad was for frenzy.
Blue was for.
I'm basically it's a speed boost blue.
Black.
Okay.
If I forget, then I just forget.
Yeah.
You just take whatever and I tell you what it is.
All right.
While you guys are still making your way through, you see Luke kind of like
run up and start barking toward where you're headed.
And Malthus you immediately can tell like there's a storm.
Wherever you're headed, like there's a heavy storm in front of you.
While you guys are making your way through, you do see
the small like merchant ship coming closer and closer to you.
And you kind of see from on top, you can probably notice Bob on the deck
moving around.
Shoot them down.
Excuse me.
You guys, I guess Bob.
Bob, we're not there yet.
We're approaching.
All right.
Don't let them while.
You don't have anything.
Do you want to shoot the swivel going at them?
Sure.
Go ahead.
This is out of care.
Roma.
Look at any shape.
Let's start shooting them.
We have no guns.
You know what your ship looks like, man.
They don't know that this is your ship.
Fuck it.
Send it Bob.
And one.
I just saw Bob and one to start thinking that that ship.
All right.
I guess he's shooting.
Twenty.
No, I'm just joking.
I'm just joking.
No.
Okay.
Both of your ships start to come closer and closer.
Kate will notice you.
Bob on the deck and he will like slow down the ship so you can board it.
As all of you board the ship.
Baptiste, you also see Guru with that tengumask.
And you can probably figure it out.
It's him because of the sword he's carrying and the guy he's with.
And you can also tell them land on your ship.
The main guy goes, you have a full assistant.
As much as you need as long as I have the mask on, it should be fine.
Let's get Dravel Sound, safe and sound.
I do have a request.
Hello.
There is a Marine on that ship by the name of Commander Leon.
A request that you do not harm him.
You can knock him out whatever as long as you get your way, but try not to kill him.
Is that a career bull?
Is there a reason behind that request?
I would rather not say.
And what about the other one?
The other one, honestly, I think it's better that we get rid of that.
He has caused me and my people a great deal of sorrow.
Unfortunately, we can do anything.
We didn't have any solid evidence to his misdeeds, but this is my only chance.
And I will take every chance I get to get to him.
Very well.
Anyway, so you're the captain.
What's the plan?
The priority is still to get Draveled out.
We'll not be that easy even if we're two complete warships.
It's going to be pretty hard to get to him right away.
Who's the female on our boat?
That's Zim.
Sorry, we're going to have to spend the game here.
Yeah, I thought she was like an old lady like covered.
I thought Vaptis shared the art for Zim a long time ago.
I didn't.
Anyway, the character art section at one point.
I have.
I didn't know that got added.
I just met him.
He looked at her.
Meenkin was like, she has no fur.
Exactly.
All right.
Getting.
Dropping out is going to be left to.
Linus in dramas.
They both have.
Means of infiltration and expiltration.
Meanwhile, the rest of us just need to.
By the time.
The guy behind.
I'm not going on a mission with that guy on the crew.
So you're just going to sit here, watch the whole time.
Let me make a call.
He walks away and just called someone up.
And go away at this point and just whisper.
It's fine.
It's going to be fine.
I'm just going to pay him a bit more.
It's all going to work out.
Don't worry about him.
I mean, I would rather not you do that.
But, you know, you are the captain.
You make the calls.
And anyways, there's also another.
Target of interest that may be in the area.
The one who's leaving be attacked.
All right.
Telling you know.
I'll glance over at mouth is in just go.
It may be.
And if it is.
That person should be helped.
I will try to keep that in mind.
All right.
It seems to be pouring hard.
And as soon as you start to come closer to the place
that the incident was important at.
You see it starts to rain down very heavy in that area.
And you start to see smoke coming out of the horizon
that you were sailing towards.
And everyone's good to go.
Everyone has their weapons set.
Everyone has their inventory good.
Anyone else?
By the way, for the sake of making this fast,
I'm going to give map Baptiste access to this guy.
Sorry, not Baptiste, Melphus.
Access to this guy.
And I'm going to use him,
Drowven and Linus and the other NPCs.
But Melphus is going to take charge of this guy.
But I just want to double check.
Baptiste you can also take charge of.
Cade.
Yeah, sorry.
Yeah, go ahead.
Do you say that?
Go ahead.
Baptiste.
Just heals, but you don't know that.
Only Baptiste knows that.
That's what I'm saying.
So look.
Yeah.
So go ahead.
I have I have the green bottle.
Yes.
So then Baptiste is the only one that knows that it heals.
Okay.
Yes.
Okay. Linus would have handed you the blue, black and red one.
The white one is already used.
Was it used completely or was it like part of it you drank?
No, I tried.
I tried.
I think you just downed it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
So you just have the black, blue and red one.
Baptiste on you.
You can distribute it within the crew, but it's up to you.
At that point.
Oh, wait.
Okay.
Cade isn't going to participate in the battle because he's going to be
a little bit more focused on the whole time.
So, you said we're coming up on it now.
The ship.
No, you still can't see anything.
You just see like heavy down for on your ship is started and you see a smoke rising up from the horizon.
Heavy down for usually suggests that there's going to be like a storm and the season not going to be like very easy to navigate going forward.
So, you know, I think it's going to be a little bit more focused on the ship.
Yeah.
Just assuming as difficult terrain.
That's what I mean.
That's it for sailing.
Malfe is take command for a moment and then I'm going below deck.
All right.
I'm going to borrow some.
Checking he's the long conscious.
Okay.
I would like to take him down from his current.
Intanglement and tie him up again.
And then start carrying him above deck.
Okay.
He's very much taller than you and he's going to be pretty heavy for whatever reasons.
So what?
What exactly?
You're dragging him.
I'm supposing.
Not like carrying him.
Yes, dragging.
Yes.
Okay.
As you drag him outside.
What do you do?
I'm just keeping him in my sight until the ship is nearby.
All right.
Okay.
Everything is currently.
Remember he is currently gagged.
Yes, currently gagged.
I see that.
I know that and everyone who's looking at it is horrified.
All right.
Lou is going to start running up to you and just jump on you and trying to be like, you know, feeling he's trying to feel secure.
And the saber tooth is back with you on the deck.
Yes.
On the deck.
Yeah.
Nice.
Can I give Bob one of my whistles and he could start training that saber tooth tiger with it?
I mean, technically he has like mine control over the saber tooth.
So it's fine.
Yeah, I can technically talk to it like within one kilometer.
But yeah, let's, you know what?
How about I take the whistle and that's how I communicate with it.
Yeah, I want that.
Sure, sure.
Okay.
Now I'm giving you both the whistles.
So the priority for Jack would always be protecting this guy.
So just keep that in mind.
Malthus going forward.
Kate is going to just handle the ship.
So he's not going to be in the fight.
What do you want Linus and Draveus to do?
They're trying to rescue Joe.
So they're just going to as soon as like the fight starts, they're just going to go and try to like face through or teleport through.
Correct.
And get to Draveus as driven as fast as possible.
Okay.
Cool.
You have him here.
Zem is just going to stay down and not really participate in the fight.
Maybe he should help out.
Kate a little bit with handling the ship.
And Roma, you ready to fuck shit up?
No, you know it.
But why is it?
I'm giving Lou to.
I'm not ready for this.
I'm handing.
Okay.
I'm just going to try and just touch the dog.
Let's see.
Oh, it's not that bad.
She takes Lou kind of like in like kind of like grabbing him,
Brian his neck away from her.
She does not really like him at all.
You better handle him with care.
Yeah, yeah, whatever.
I'll try to take care of this thing.
Zem.
What?
I'm only taking care of your ship.
What else do you want from me?
To stay safe.
All right.
You better stay safe.
Okay.
All right.
As you are sailing toward into the thunderstorm,
you start to see the scene in front of you more clearly.
Let me figure out.
It should be black.
Bobbugs.
Oh, is it back?
Yes, it is.
It's completely blind.
I think I'm still loading it.
Yeah.
There we go.
Why isn't it let me give this?
Give what?
My whistles to Bob.
Is that don't want this shit?
That's fine, that's fine.
Just we'll take care of that later.
There we go.
Oh.
It's loud.
It's supposed to be loud.
You can turn down the environment.
Yeah, I'm doing it.
I was already doing that.
Yeah, yeah.
That's the problem.
Okay.
Let me see.
I'm going to figure out the scale.
I didn't really check for it.
Are you guys able to see anything?
No, not yet.
Okay.
That was well.
Yeah.
Just trying to figure out.
Yeah, it's fine.
Okay, there we go.
We only need the people who will be actually fighting.
So I'm just going to bring only the ones that are fighting.
Bob, there we go.
Okay.
I'm there.
I'm going to leave out.
Melco, there we go.
Roma, there we go.
Oh, shit.
And I'm going to move in.
Who's going to be fighting?
No, no, Zim, Zim, Zim.
I mean, the people on the ship need to be on the ship, right?
Or Zim.
You're full.
Zim.
And Kate.
And Trevo's.
And Linus.
I have so many folders of so many characters.
Now it's kind of getting ridiculous.
So he's killing people off.
I need to clear shit up, bro.
Okay, let me get the other guy to go.
There we go.
We have all our players.
And the tiger.
Do you have ownership of this?
Oh, no.
I don't know.
Let me give you the ownership so you can just use the token.
Where is it?
Did you like put the tokens like character sheet to the saber one and the chat?
They do have different HPs, right?
Yeah, I did have different HPs.
So I'm just going to move the token for the saber one so you can just use that instead.
I'm just going to move the token in for the just give you once.
Is it in lunar folds?
Did you add it in lunar folds?
Yes.
Okay.
All right.
So in front of you, you just see two very different looking marine ships.
One has like these energy powered cannons and one of them is pretty much like your normal
warship.
And on this one, you have like a mast head of some kind.
And on the other one, there's no, there's just like a clean warship with the marine sigil on it.
And behind all of that, you can see like a big wreck.
And the whole ship seems to be just scorched in flame as it's starting to capsize.
You can hear the screams of the Marines coming off of that ship as all of the cannons on these warships are concentrated
to fire at something that is flying around there.
You catch glimpse of it, but you can't really tell from this far away.
And let me switch up the music.
What the fuck did you get us into?
Go.
All right.
Go ahead.
It's not the vibes.
It is very not the way.
Let's go.
You see Linus and Draivos create like a small pipe from the ground.
And they will ask you to enter it.
Where do you want this to be?
I can only get you to here.
That is my range.
That is Draivos's range.
I just have to reload.
Can you read so where?
I can't read it.
He said his range is about here.
So wherever the PVC pipe can show up is about here.
So we have the gas which ship the boat which ship trouble is on the middle one.
This kind of puts us in a bad spot.
My line.
Which ship seems to be the most guarded.
Again, all of the ships have told you the description for the ships.
You can see like slight differences on the ship on the token itself.
It's just up to you to figure out which ship he would be on.
And the one ship that's behind you can see that it's like the ship of this type.
But just capsizing.
We're just going to have to trust our instincts.
Yeah.
If there are two of those kind of ships, they have the armed ones that might be that he's on this one.
The other one.
We're going in this one.
Which one this one?
Yeah.
The other one.
Wait, this one or this one?
I mean, you can only realistically get to this one, right?
That's what I'm saying.
Okay.
Linus looks at you as he jumps through the pipe and goes as soon as I'm on that boat,
I will pass through with draves and get back.
Get to word drove and as soon as possible.
It will be up to you to fight off all the enemies on there.
All right, Baptiste.
Just checking.
Linus does have a radio.
Correct.
You can check him one.
Yeah, I'll check him the one I had.
Yeah.
We both check him one.
He grabs both.
He goes.
I think you should have one of these, right?
Yes, he chucks one back to you, Baptiste.
And he puts one in his pocket and just jumps in the pipe.
And at this point, who wants to follow in?
Who wants to go first?
These two will just be out of your sight.
As soon as they're in there,
they will be just gone from your side.
So you won't be able to see him.
I'm the captain.
So I'll go first.
All right.
Let's do the sample.
The sample.
As soon as you get on the shot,
you see about like seven to eight Marines dressed very peculiarly.
And you can feel like they're not like your regular type of Marines.
All right, who's following behind Baptiste?
Baptiste, you can just fly anywhere by the way.
Yeah, I got my own shit to do.
Yeah.
Who's following after Baptiste?
Is there a space?
I guess Bob and his saber to the go.
Nobody wants to come.
No, you're alone.
All right.
After you, the saber to barely fits in the pipe,
but it makes it through.
Bob, same with you.
Sorry, Roma, same with you as you follow through.
The other two also follow through as the pipe starts to dissipate
and just go back in the ground.
Let me move all of you into combat.
Let's go.
Bob, you can't be in front of me.
That's illegal.
Why am I in the water?
Let me move you in.
Because you got the wings.
Plus 50 feet.
I'm going to go back in the water.
Yeah.
Okay.
There we go.
You should be start for from here.
Let's get some good initiative, bros, you guys.
All right.
The Marines will share the same.
And it pulls.
So I'm just going to roll for one and just going to sign that one to
everyone.
And then you can go back in the water.
Yeah.
The warhorse shares your turn, right?
Or does it have like a different turn?
So it only works on your turn, right?
Yes.
Do you use a bonus action or just?
No, it works on his own, but after my turn.
Okay.
So the action economy is from the warhouse.
It's just you are working on the same initiative.
Yeah.
Well, the gore was an issue.
We're old for gore-oo.
Very bad.
Probably.
Okay.
Melphus 2.
Oh, it's not a lot.
Let me check.
I have no idea.
Configure sheet.
No.
Product time.
Okay.
I think it's because of this.
We're just going to put jacket here for now.
All right.
Here we go.
Who was first?
The faster guy.
What do you think it's first?
Melphus, as you fly toward this part, you immediately are shot by someone.
There we go.
Out of the air.
Oh, sorry.
No, wrong one.
Sorry.
This one.
13.
This is.
Okay.
It's okay.
Thank you.
18.
This is.
It's my AC.
Okay.
It also misses.
So it's up to you.
If you move forward, even little, it will hit you again.
You can try to determine where the shot is coming from.
I can't.
Okay.
You can clearly tell that the shot that shot you came from somewhere around here.
Yeah.
Not a good sign.
Hmm.
Yeah, mouth is anthem right now.
And it's storming, so there's extra fun.
Yeah.
Why is it always so bad?
What the fuck?
This is my domain now.
All right, I'm going to say it's going to cover both of the, even all of the three
ships damn. All right, but I'm going to remove this.
Blocking everything. There we go.
Fair.
Go ahead.
Yeah, I'm just going to bolt a guy down and I shot me.
Call lightning is, does it cause damage all throughout or you can select?
It's not going to be when it causes a spelt.
You can see when it's arranged.
Okay, so you're just going to five feet on that point make a deck safe.
All right, so you're just going to smite this area.
Yeah.
How much, how much area is it?
How much AoE?
Within five feet of that.
So it's 10 feet.
Okay, 10 feet.
10 feet will only get one of these guys.
All right, back safe, please.
Next safe.
15.
That succeeds.
Still take all damage.
Okay, roll damage.
And since it's storming, I get an extra detent.
Yes.
No, I.
Of course.
So that's eight.
Okay, let me apply as half a damage.
There we go.
You see as you direct like the lightning as it's going on around you,
the thunder is bursting through the air as you redirect one of the lightning strikes
to this particular location.
And out of that smoke, you don't see the person that definitely shot you.
You seem to have missed him, but the person nearby gets struck by that lightning.
Is that your action, I think, right?
Yeah, that's my action.
Do you want to move?
Oh, yeah, I can't move anymore because you skipped my door.
Oh, look around a bit farther.
Again, as soon as you move, you're going to get shot.
Fine.
I mean, you can still move.
And if it misses, you can move that distance.
Yeah, oh, so you move.
All right.
Let me.
Okay, 23.
Okay, do the damage.
What?
What do you mean technically 10?
I was talking about myself.
Okay, okay.
That's eight fourths damage.
And you're also.
Can you make a strength save?
Yeah, I can also catch the bullet.
You can also try to do that.
But the strength save you will still have to make.
That's just for an effect.
Oh, no.
20.
You don't get knocked prone, but are you trying to catch the bullet?
Yeah, and I all mentally catch because it's less than the thing I can do.
Okay.
As soon as you grab the bullet, you see the you feel the pressure of the bullet still knocking you.
15 feet behind where you were shot at.
So from here, you will be pushed 15 feet behind.
Can you make a deck save?
So see, to see if you are still in the air or not.
But I didn't take damage.
Yeah, it's fine.
The force is still there.
It's not part of the action.
Part of the action would have been you just get knocked down completely.
13.
You should be able to stabilize yourself, but you will drop about like 50 feet.
Sorry, 15 feet behind.
All right.
As soon as you get within the range of this place,
you see from beneath you.
Why is it slowing down?
Is it my PC?
That's one.
What the hell?
My mouse is acting up.
Is it better now?
I'm going to turn down the rain.
I think it's fucking up my.
Shit.
How do I turn it off?
God damn it.
How does this struggling?
Ambiance?
Ambiance.
But assume that the rain is still there.
We're good.
Where's my token of the guy go?
What the fuck?
Wait, is it darkness in here or like dim light?
It's probably dim, but not like dark dark.
This is still like in the middle of the day.
Where's the middle of the storm?
Where did my token go?
Did I delete the token?
One guy left.
Okay.
As you push back, let me see.
Where is that?
Oh, that's easy.
There we go.
You see this guy behind you?
He catches your attention as he takes out like this sword that he's
carrying and he's just going to shoot like slashes of his sword
attack towards you.
Does the guy there need to keep alive?
What?
Where's the guy who needs to keep alive for a Coru?
You just know he's the name of Commander Leon.
That guy.
Yeah.
There we go.
Nine.
Is that slashing damage or piercing?
So it's just full, right?
You don't take half.
All right.
There we go.
Wait, do you have how much?
Okay.
That's fine.
I thought that you had a bit more than I.
Been below you.
You just feel like these slashes over here.
Just this pass you the first one misses at the second one.
Slashes your shoulder.
Can you make another deck safe?
Yeah.
You just me that struggling or is it you guys too?
I'm fine.
Did more cards just above?
Yes.
Now on the other side of the vessel.
That's 17, right?
17.
It's a warship.
There's kind of this bound to be like a lot of people on it.
No, I know.
All right.
Yeah, you should be able to calm yourself.
I finally move.
Yeah, you can finally move.
Get me over there.
Wait, how much does this do you move?
I couldn't move before because I was going back.
I was like, yeah, move there.
And I would like, yo, you go back here.
You have only the, what, how much movement do you have?
80.
So you move 50, right?
Yeah.
On the ship as soon as you reach the ship,
you don't see any signs of the flying creature that you spotted from down there.
But you do see a bunch of Marines trying to get each other out to safety.
They will not probably engage you.
They're just more worried about getting out of the sinking ship.
That's fine.
All right.
Okay, let's see.
And the next one is about to taste.
Yes, the plan.
What's the plan, man?
My office is doing his own thing.
Understandably so.
So let's start off with the good old.
Oh, what the, who just, was that me?
No, that was not me.
But it could go dying.
Like good old.
Haste.
So.
And then.
Some arms.
And.
Pop over here.
Double checking.
Pop marks.
Got them.
What was the save deck save, right?
Yeah.
Five.
All of them will fail.
One, two, three, four.
This one is still long.
This one will be.
We'll be on the right.
Yeah.
How many feet?
Yeah, it's 10.
10.
Okay.
One, two, three, three of them are off the ship.
The, this one will take the damage.
This one will take the damage.
And this one will take the damage.
It's three.
I got a little damage roll.
Is it?
How much was it?
Three.
Yeah.
But don't you worry since I haste that I have one more action left.
I choose you to eat.
One more attack left.
Yeah.
I don't know if it's one action because of pace.
No, no.
No, it's one attack.
All right.
Wait, let me read it.
Because it says somebody is.
If you choose your tag action,
there you can't note your attack again.
That's actually a tag.
Is it not?
Yeah, you can multitack twice, right?
You can chain multi attacks.
So it's not actions.
It's just attack.
Let me see.
Oh, yeah.
Let's hack.
What?
Oh, oh wow.
Okay.
Well, you guys still dashed this in case high.
So do you know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
I'll run up on the mofo.
Mofo.
Step up.
Some more.
And I don't need to go up there far.
I have read.
All right.
Let's see how the roles are today.
Not good.
Okay.
Good start.
You use your bonus.
So that's your action.
What else?
Yeah.
Haste.
Oh, haste already.
Yeah.
Okay.
All right.
Next is.
You know what?
I'm just going to change it name because it's confusing.
Displade name.
Check.
There we go.
All right.
Jack.
It's.
Well, there is a guy next to me.
Yeah.
But you are also long-rangeed.
So.
Do you have a thing for that?
I don't know if you do.
I think I have a thing that I don't think this is long-term.
Disadvantage.
I think I'm going to have to do that.
Maybe.
I'm not going anywhere.
Don't wear that probably.
Maybe.
Anyway, I would like crossbow mastery or something.
Yeah, I think I think you have that.
18.
18 will hit.
Noise.
The image.
Oh.
It's that.
Tussy.
Is that it?
I got a second attack.
Mm-hmm.
There.
No more.
16.
And I will hit.
18.
Nice.
This.
And then.
Help out.
So basically, as soon as Baptiste moves in, he just shoves off all these people.
And then, as soon as he gets in, he just throws a guy, just straight up,
comes flying towards you.
You just take two of your revolts and bam, bam, straight through his body.
He still seems to be alive, but he is very injured.
Let me see.
I don't want to be next to those guys.
I'll back to the pipe.
No, the pipe's gone.
No.
Do you have dark vision?
It's still enough to see.
No, just asking for something.
Let's have a look.
How far can I run?
Oh, great.
I don't want to run over here.
Where does it hit me?
Five times once.
So that's five feet.
Hey, listen.
So what does it do?
It's the second thing.
It calls your opponent to maintain it.
Probably quite long enough to.
Enough for you to flee as a bonus.
I can't expect one of the two dead to move a number of feet.
It equals to the five X, the number, you know, so five, okay, five one.
Love your horse, you two fads.
Just get on top of the horse.
You know, I'm going to just throw him into the ocean.
That's fine.
You could just bring him back.
I have intentionally not kept any boundaries because I knew it would fucking cause problems.
There are a lot of people.
That's your action.
That's your turn right?
Yeah.
All right.
All of the Marines will now engage one by one, starting with this Marine who has been capsized.
So we will just remove him from the turn order for now.
And then this Marine who you just threw is going to stop, look behind, look at the captain.
He goes, captain, I'm sorry, but it seems to be that some pirates have onboarded her ship.
The Marine right beside him just looks with a blank stare and just brandishes his weapon as he starts moving towards you Baptist.
And the Marine right alongside him is going to take out his rifle and shoot.
I should always just do multi attack, but I'm just going to just do it twice.
There we go.
Six and five critically misses.
Is that a question?
Is he shooting a partner?
We're not going with that rules, but if you want to, we can do that now.
But then just remember every time Jack shoots and he rolls a.
I love critical games and games.
Okay, so we want to do it.
We're deciding on it.
It's a pretty good.
Well, that's from trajectory as well, right?
And there's no one around.
You can't really like.
Yeah, honestly, it's just on that one.
So it's not that bad.
Yeah, it's just on that one.
So you have potential to hit in any ally.
Yeah, yeah, that's fine.
It's only on range two.
So that's also fine.
Well, you can also hit someone in the face every.
Yeah, but that's like that's like a bit more like.
It's all.
If we're both in one everything.
Yeah, just.
That was consequences now.
No, not for everything.
Are we the only four?
Now we have that one.
Oh,
Okay, let's decide it right now.
Do we want to do it for melee two or not?
Yeah.
Oh, so from now, if anyone else of your ally is in melee range,
it will hit them instead of natural.
On that one.
Yes.
Okay, as soon as he shoots the first one, it goes like straight through you.
The second one kind of clogs up as he's like kind of trying to.
What do you say?
Fucking.
It gets damned as he's trying to move.
He positions it towards the captain and he just shoots.
I'm going to roll the damage.
Was he trying to shoot me this whole time?
Yeah, probably.
Yeah, he's just standing there like.
The bullet goes like kind of like through his like the burn scar on his cheek.
It just grazes that part as the captain kind of puts his hand on the marine and goes.
Calm yourself.
You have a job to do.
He will take that damage.
Here we go.
Next is.
This marine is down.
So I'm just going to remove him from the.
Hello.
What's next?
This marine is also.
All right.
This marine will take out his cutlass and he is going to shoot you.
Bob.
Is it a cutlass sword?
Yes.
So when he was not sure.
He was not sure.
He's going to shoot his cutlass now.
That's what I was asking.
14 and 11.
Both of them miss.
Do not be 19.
I know.
They're very incapable apparently.
This marine who is like barely standing.
He looks at you, Roma.
And he's going to make a decision for himself right now.
Overboards.
That's Roma.
Hi.
Yeah.
He is just going to take the chance of sinking into the sea.
And he just jumps off board.
Jesus.
He can be so.
Roma.
He's going to do anything.
That's what I'm saying.
It is just like.
All right.
I'm out.
Where's this one?
Which one is this one?
Where the fuck am I?
What?
I don't know.
Oh, this this marine.
Okay.
How so what the fuck is happening?
This marine will charge at you, Bob Teased.
And he is going to use his cutlass again.
Miss.
You know, you can say that.
Uh, what the fuck happened?
He missed.
14 and eight.
Is it?
Oh, yeah.
It was.
It's okay.
He missed both.
Is it getting close?
Or word miss?
What?
Our word miss.
Power for her to miss.
This marine will flank you and this time you will do it with the advantage.
Miss.
Okay.
Uh, oh my god.
Why is my mouth acting up?
I don't understand.
Vanish.
Tag.
21.
I think no one wants to answer it.
Just barely.
Seven.
Uh, as this marine runs around and he slashes at you twice.
But this time just hits you at one of the parts.
Uh, concentration check, please.
All right.
He's just.
Up.
Uh, up.
Teased.
Up.
Okay.
Jesus Christ.
I'm going to drop.
It took seven damage.
Wait, did you take seven damage?
Aren't you like last marine to something he will run up?
He will have to activate his element in domain.
Yeah.
Unless he does that.
It doesn't work.
Uh, let me.
Uh, Carlos.
Miss.
Um, armor as it still slices through one of your actual arms into your body.
It beats an AC.
It's 20.
21.
Uh, yeah, all of that happens.
He just slices through the astral thing, not act not your actual body.
So you're fine.
But you do see that this person can use hockey.
You don't know what hockey is.
But you know, you've heard about it.
Tag this marine.
Uh, well, you don't know if all of them can use it or not.
That's why I said that was.
That's what I particularly.
Special cakes right here.
My new butler.
You must still have one.
All right.
Let me see.
I'm going to do another.
27 hits you.
Malthus or not.
Right.
I don't need to ask.
Nine.
Uh, can you make a strength save?
Sure.
Oh, holy shit, bro.
This time you see the.
Flying, yeah, flying towards you.
As you grab it and it's going to push you back.
But you take no damage.
I'm going to revert that damage.
Uh, I don't know why it made the damage already.
But you are going to get pushed.
So, bro, it's so confusing.
What?
20.
Okay.
15 feet.
The trajectory of the ballad is this way.
Can you make a deck saves to see if you're still a float?
I didn't think that was.
Again, it's four.
So you get pushed back regardless.
Pop in Mac.
Pop one.
Of course.
Uh, all right.
You start to free fall 50 feet and we'll come back to that on your turn.
All right, Bob, finally.
Uh, since you explicitly said it was dim light, I get to use something that I couldn't use earlier because it was bright light every combat.
Uh, there.
How do you use it?
Where is it?
Supply.
There you go.
And it is applied and.
Why is it not showing in the chat?
What do you do to show it in the chat?
Uh, yeah.
So all bright light within 20 feet of the weapon becomes dim light and dim light becomes darkness.
So as Bob coats his weapon in his dark blood, the fumes surround him and within 20 feet, every dim light is darkness now.
So I'm assuming these guys can't don't have dark vision.
So I'm assuming that his blinded.
Yep.
Sorry, how much?
20 feet?
Yeah.
Let me see how much.
I'll just move a bit further just to not give my guys blinded condition.
I mean, okay.
I was facing the marker, man.
Oh, uh, regardless.
It will be huge.
Uh, every one.
Goddamn.
You want to move, move, and just bam, bam.
Two attacks, please.
No, no, no.
Roma, you can, you have dark vision, right?
So you define.
Yeah.
Even darkness.
Even magical darkness or no?
No, it says normal darkness.
I don't know the rules, but it doesn't mention the word magical.
So I don't know.
You have, you have advantage.
Uh, go ahead.
Let's just test the waters.
Uh, manage.
Does that hit?
Yes.
Uh, damage.
Oh, wait.
No, it's okay.
Normal.
Uh, 26.
It hits.
And another one.
Uh, attack, please.
Let's advantage.
Uh, doesn't it?
23 hit.
Uh, I'll just do that damage.
And so, 226.
So 52 damage.
Okay.
How do you want to kill this Marine?
Just.
Yeah, just double fly sim.
And.
All right.
You spread that darkness as, uh, you raised your halberd and just slice into him twice.
And that's going to be the end of this one.
And then I'm going to move on because I again don't know if the girl who guy has dark vision.
So I want to move over here, uh, with my whole 30 feet of movement.
Is it concentrated on you?
Yes.
Always.
On my weapon, not me.
So technically on me.
Hello.
You probably should have automated this instead of doing that.
Okay.
I don't know why it's not doing any aura kind of thing.
Does it, does the end of you don't do that?
Uh, never mind.
So I'm over here.
So, uh, malphous 2 and goro does not have blinded condition anymore.
So that's the end of my turn.
Also, uh, every single guy around Baptist is in darkness right now.
So his attacks would have advantage as well.
Bob, I love you.
When you're trying to kill me like earlier, like, five minutes ago.
No.
I don't recall.
There we go.
Is this guy?
Oh, I think it just.
You just made my turn easier.
All right.
It's goers turn and he is going to.
Take this guy out.
He would have advantage because that guy is also within darkness.
Is he?
I mean, okay, you decide.
I don't know.
Yeah, I think he's on the border.
Okay, advantage.
20.
Okay.
You see he places his blade into the sheet.
He raises, uh, his other arm in front of him.
And just takes the blade as he slices the other guy is just next as.
He just steps from this direction to this.
Why is he not moving?
Okay, I have it.
As he just slops his head off.
We go.
Next is Roma.
Well, seeing how pretty much 90% of the people are dead.
I'm not.
How far is this 15 feet?
Oh, I can move that.
I can move that.
We can go right up here.
And since because this dude, he's dead.
He's dead.
Yep.
Oh, I'm going to.
Let's look here.
How do I want to do this?
I'm going to.
Is Roma still human?
Yes.
Even after transforming because of the formula.
You missed that last bite because you were asleep.
Yeah.
Um, I'm popping that this.
I'm going to use this while also getting angry at the same time.
I don't think you can do that.
This is another bonus action.
I'm both a bonus action.
Oh, I thought.
I thought going a hybrid form was a regular action.
No, it's a bonus action.
You can get.
You can do both if you want to just leave the regular action.
Out.
So you can use one attack.
I'll give you that.
That's it.
With the hybrid and rage, I'll give you one attack.
That's what I'm saying.
OK.
There we go.
You want to attack?
I don't want to do this.
How do you?
Can I pick him up and throw him at this dude over here?
Yes.
That's what I'm doing.
Is that a strength check?
That is a strength check.
Oh.
Why am I not?
There we go.
Athletics and acrobatics.
Would that be with advantage since I'm raging?
Yeah, you are in the darkness areas.
You do with advantage because you have advantage on everything who has blinded it.
19.
He still somehow makes it through the acrobatics check.
He dodges you.
And I think that's your turn.
Yep.
Mouses.
As you are plummeting to the ocean, you feel a tug on your hand as you're thrown back onto the ship.
Oh.
Again, it's on the ground.
You can't see that far away.
But you do see a flying figure in the sky circling as it lands somewhere around here.
But as soon as you arrive on the ship, you start to engage with the Marines who see you as a threat now.
Wouldn't they help us fucking us?
You just fucking a bird landed on thing. They think it's you.
They just got to start you and.
But it's not their turn so they wouldn't shoot right now, but you can move.
Or try to take them down.
It's up to you.
Yeah.
Fucking both these two dudes.
So here so it's in five feet of both.
Yeah.
All right.
As one of the other, like me strikes strikes through you curve it as it lands in front of these two.
Roll the damage.
Well, they're safe.
Oh, sorry.
Just roll the damage anyway.
I just have to have it.
Oh, good.
They saved the right.
Okay.
Apply half a damage.
There we go.
All right.
Next move.
But you're gonna say to them.
Up.
Don't you have better days to do right now.
Get yourself out of this ship before you collapse with it.
The kind of lower their weapons as they rush to each other and carry each other out.
And try to swim their way over to the ship.
All right.
As you make your way through the, yeah, as you're making your way through this area,
you see a bunch of Marines are lying under like this fiery log trapped in there.
Let me.
All three of these Marines are under like piles of just burning cinder logs.
All right.
Let's you move, right?
That's my action.
I don't have a bow section.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, let me check.
You know, for one of the last times, let me roll that dice.
Let's see.
I've had that one before.
Yeah, I roll the, I do think I roll.
Let me see what it is.
When you use Flurry of Blows, you ignore Spirit.
Jesus.
Oh, that one.
Fucking roll.
But that's me.
That's me for now.
That's you.
All right.
Next is Commander Leon.
He will dash out of the darkness.
And that means he can't see.
Thanks for telling us that.
And he will send bursts off.
Tempest kicks.
So please, everyone within this area, which is Roma, Baptist, and Bob, make a deck.
I forgot my name.
Sure.
Is that a deck, sir?
Yes.
Is that a yellow?
No, no, no, he will yell out duck as soon as he just fires where his tempest kick.
Why are there such duck, Roma's getting that we?
Yeah, we're doing it well.
I mean, okay, sure, you can try again.
That's the next day for.
So do the Marines make a deck safe to?
No.
I mean, you can understand like this is their strategy.
They are more prepared to handle this.
Yeah, we heard nothing in the storm.
Yeah.
Oh, it's because I have that fail.
Okay.
Why with advantage?
I mean, you can't do that.
What kind of damage is it?
It's lashing.
Ew.
Why do we?
Roma takes half because I think he has slashing resistance.
Yeah.
Rage, right?
Bob takes full.
And you take full as well, right?
E. I think half.
Half, half, half.
There we go.
And that is, let me see if I have multi-attack.
And two strikes.
Do we have concentration saves on your gloom thing, Bob?
No.
Okay.
It's not a spell.
He's just going to yell out, men, just stay out of the way.
And he's just going to slash.
And I'm just going to roll to see if he hits someone or not.
Roll one, two, three.
Since he's getting one of his rage, his rapier has huge range.
It's just like, you know, air slashes.
Two, that's going to be Baptiste.
If he's attacking, miss.
Is that not disadvantage work?
Oh, yeah, sorry, sorry, sorry.
I'm going to do it with a good call.
You know, that's where you're the captain.
You know why?
Good for you.
It wasn't that 20.
So it doesn't really matter.
I'm going to roll damage.
So that's going to be 17, 13, 17 piercing.
17.
Let me check.
Six fours and 14.
So I think six is half.
Yeah, that's why it's 17.
Okay.
Your force resistant, right?
Yeah.
Okay.
I'm going to do the 17.
And I'm going to make another one with this advantage.
And of course, I low roll on that freaking cup.
All right, hastes out.
Ten misses.
So the two slashes, one of them just directly hits you.
Baptiste as the other one completely like wizards through the darkness.
And that's going to be it.
Baptiste, you're turned.
You can see him.
You can see everything essentially.
Jesus, my health.
Yeah.
It's always him.
For some reason.
Start off.
From this action.
All right.
At least you have the damage from now on.
Um.
Let's get rid of some Marines first.
Wait.
Oh.
Why do it?
Do you?
Do I?
Why are you doing?
I want to have fun.
I'm doing it.
What's he doing?
Since you wanted to take out my haste.
The whole back half of the ship is now.
Hell.
All right.
Didn't you use all your three things for haste?
Because of the Lunarion.
Yeah, it's a spell.
Oh, I see.
Keep forgetting.
The whole back.
You want to turn this to Motov-
Hell.
Again, blinded.
Okay.
There we go.
I need to make a wisdom save.
He's going to use the legendary resistance.
And just jump on top of the
ship.
You see.
That was possible.
What?
I thought about putting the template back that far.
But then I'll be like, he can't do that.
That's illegal.
This guy is.
Did he fail?
No, I didn't make a save from him.
Wait.
Can he move on like this turn?
He uses the legendary resistance.
Yeah, but that makes him succeed on the role.
But how is he moving?
Does he have legendary actions as well?
Yeah, legendary actions, legendary resistance.
It doesn't matter.
He can't move in legendary actions either.
If you want to keep him there, it's not just the,
but it's not just the legendary resistance.
It's not just the legendary resistance.
It doesn't really matter.
He's going to move regardless of that.
Okay, he fails.
This one fails.
I'm just going to take the same role for both of these.
So just do the damage.
What was it?
23.
Yeah.
Apply.
All right.
That's your move, right?
You want to move?
Yeah, because I'm fine where I'm at.
Jack.
Sorry, sorry.
Right after your turn, he's going to use his legendary action
to flashstep.
And then...
Tempest kick.
Make another save everyone in this area.
He's just going to 30 feet here.
And then boom.
I'm just trying to keep him out of the
range.
I'm just trying to keep him out of the range.
I'm just going to hit the wall next to Roma.
You are just confusing the Lunarians.
But now you're not racist anymore.
I'm not racist anymore.
I'm just stupid.
We're still too little Aryans here.
Technically, there's more.
We don't know that.
We just don't know.
Yeah.
So, want me to roll this fetish.
I mean, it's up to you.
You might still target this guy.
I'm just going to target the captain.
Pit fill.
Oh, please.
We have pit fill.
I don't get too much hope to the captain.
So, yeah.
But now I'm still following his orders.
I'm not saying that.
But it will miss.
Well, then I have another thing for that.
Okay, Shay.
Yeah.
So I can ricochet bullets.
Roll again.
I'm just going to hit the guy.
There we go.
All right.
As you try to focus in your trajectory,
you shoot at the guy.
It misses the first time.
The second time you shoot the one of the Bullen's bounces off.
And it's the other guy.
I still have my second shot.
Yeah.
I'm just going to hit the guy.
Fuck you.
That'd be fucked.
I'd bob your down and the darkness.
I think subsides with you or no.
Yes.
Aye, it's done.
Bob, how much damage did you take?
He took the most damage from that guy.
Yeah, he took almost all of the damage from him because he failed both of the saves.
Like, I could have healed myself to full like in my next turn, but you had to kill me in this one.
Yes.
I don't know what's going on.
Yeah, I don't need you.
You decided this.
You decided this literally at the start of I already had.
He didn't give up the opposite.
Yeah.
I would like let me nice.
Wait, what if the damage happens?
Does the damage happen when they start their turn or when you make the modal pile?
Because they already took damage.
I was just wondering if the damage at the wrong time or not.
The creature who starts their turn in the area takes 36 fire damage, but it's 36 when they
end their turn or not.
They're psychic in.
Wait, I didn't hear you.
The end part.
What was it?
It's 36 when they start 36 on the end.
Okay.
So at the start, this guy took the damage.
This guy took the damage.
I'm just going to say all three of them took the damage at the start already.
So this guy will move, loop around, jump around him.
And you know what?
I'm just going to not try to flank or anything.
I'm just going to fucking attack.
Okay.
He will have plus one EC because of formation fighting and he will attack you twice.
He's not blinded anymore.
Yes.
Miss.
18 and 10.
Both of them miss.
I fucking hate this.
Okay.
This guy will also try to run away.
That piece you can try swinging at him.
You know why I will.
I know why I will.
I really just reorganized my favorite steps.
So now everything is not right.
15 won't hit.
What?
It's probably 16.
It is.
You can use your insight to get a read on this guy.
Is it really just is this the same guy that you talk to your.
No, no, no, no, no, it was this guy.
I'm just joking.
I was just trying to get you to waste your thing for an hour.
Yeah, that's your only move.
I don't know what I'm waiting for.
Yeah, so he's just going to run away and try to get through you.
Roma.
Oh, ho, ho, ho.
See, is that Roma became French 11?
18 heads are now.
It does it.
Yes.
The 11.
Does he?
Yeah, you get 4 half of slashing.
There we go.
How are you still on your 10 HP?
How the hell?
How much 10 HP did you have?
I have no idea.
I'm just joking.
Should have 25.
That starts.
Yeah, yeah, I think he had 45, right?
25.
Five times your level.
What the fuck?
Okay, so how much is the bird thing again that he starts with like his HP as a
10 HP?
No.
And six.
He took in total 11.
Four, 17.
Yeah, 11.
17.
So 13.
Now I'm going to move it down to 13 because I think he did start with 25
10 HP.
I think it's just automation issue.
Okay.
You still are on your 10 HP somehow.
All right.
He hits you.
And that's going to be his turn.
It's going to be this Marines turn.
And he's going to try to attack him.
Marine Cutless.
Attack, attack, attack, attack, attack.
Both of them will hit.
Why are they petty officer Marines?
Why are they petty for?
I don't know why they're petty man.
It's just their post.
It's just their rank.
They just petty officers.
I know he was trying to make a joke.
Yeah, it doesn't work.
Because it's an actual rank.
We have to smart for it.
This guy is going to maneuver himself out of that first.
And he's going to circle around Roma.
So he gets advantage.
And again, he's using.
The set no.
It only works when they move out of the five feet.
Yes.
11 does not hit.
But with the three, it still does not hit.
14.
No.
Yeah, you need to.
Sorry with another.
It's a advantage.
He's still so bad.
Another one.
I manage.
The hockey point was wasted on the first one.
So this is not without hockey essentially.
Nine.
But he's still so bad.
So he's still so bad.
So that's the first one.
So that's the second one.
And it's the first one.
So that's the first one.
So that's the second one.
And then he's going to go to the next one.
So that's the first one.
But the first one.
And then he's going to go to the next one.
And he's going to do the multi-attack.
A-
Normal.
18.
Misses it right?
It's my UC.
It's having also misses.
Nice.
You see the bullet flying from this place this time.
Straight to you twice.
But it misses.
And it's going to be his turn.
All right, Bob.
You are dead.
But I'm just saving throw.
Get again.
And that's the failure.
That's failure.
Nice.
That's the end of the...
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
That's the end of my turn.
But I forgot it earlier.
But at the end of my turn, the saber-to-targer goes.
And since it's supposed to protect me,
it's probably going to just start attacking anyone,
except for the crew.
All right.
What do you want it to do?
So he's going to attack the person who is right next to me.
So...
No.
How much is this?
Is this...
Is this 20 feet of movement?
Yes.
No, no. He was on...
I'm going to assume he has been like in your range.
So it's not going to be any movement.
That's fine.
Wasn't he at over here at this point?
Sure, but I was assuming he was like with you on your turns.
Yeah, but I forgot his turn.
Because if he was on...
With me on my turn, he would have attacked the earlier turn.
I was sure, sure.
He moves 20 feet.
And this is why I was selling you this.
Because I know.
I know.
You have a bounce?
Yes.
[Whistling]
You're...
Let's see if it does not have a dark question.
Just so you know.
It does.
It's a mild oil mount.
It's your mild oil mount.
It does have...
But there's also no dark generally.
Apparently.
I don't think the character she...
Does the character she for the thing has dark origin?
We're going to see it here.
Check the journal.
It has the actual step-block.
I see it.
All right, try to...
Did Jack have one leg?
What?
No.
What do you mean?
I'm looking at his picture.
No, no.
It's true legs.
One leg is like on the wall behind him.
Yeah.
It looks like he's gonna...
And when you see the full picture,
it's on the character art, I think.
Oh, top, yeah.
No, it's like leading against the wall with one leg.
Any other one?
All right.
This...
No, see we're in damage to this guy.
Do I have to make a...
Yeah, because it hit him.
All right.
What does the...
Strength save his four?
That's a failure.
What is it for, Prom?
It is for Prom.
That guy is for now and...
And he's taking 17 damage.
Essentially, like the saber tooth is going to leap on him
and just, you know, claw at him.
And now it makes another attack with its slam attack
as a bonus action.
All right.
Do you still...
I've not done a good job with making it...
You're doing well enough because...
I mean, I am not the one who does fondry.
I know, but...
I thought it was ready.
I can't know when.
It's been spent spent.
I don't want to refer to the thing again and again.
That's what I'm saying.
And that's just fine.
And there's the end of his turn.
I'm just going to say,
because the saber tooth is just going to kill the guy.
Not at all.
I mean, yeah, I can't.
Yeah, yeah.
I don't know if you want to control over it.
All right.
So, this guy is more to that right behind you, Baptiste.
Next is Roma.
I'm sorry.
It was Goro.
Goro.
We're almost like bro.
Let me fight.
That's a failure.
And...
That's a success.
Let me do the damage.
14.
All right.
Okay.
Fucking the whole verse.
All right.
As soon as he makes his attack, you see him kind of stumble.
And fall into like one of the cannons
off to the side, Jack.
Oh shit.
Roma, two tanks.
All right.
So, for my two attacks,
I'm going to take my frying pan
and basically spin around in a circle.
Like a whirlwind attack?
Yeah.
I'm going to use my action
to do a third attack.
All right.
Roll twice first
and then roll the third time.
Yes.
And then since I'm raging,
you know what that means.
Right.
Well,
13 on the first one.
So be 17 on the first one.
13.
Okay.
We have this one's going to be the second one.
Oh, that's 19.
That's critical, baby.
The second one is the first one.
Roll the damage for the first one.
Okay.
Did you not roll the.
I did.
Okay.
I quick to twice.
Just do just do normal first
and then do critical next one.
Supply.
Okay.
So normal is
eight damage.
Eight.
Okay.
Yeah.
I was hovering over you.
Okay.
Now roll for critical for the same one.
I don't think it's possible.
Yeah.
I want to just just just attack again.
Whatever the role is.
Just do the critical.
Yeah.
I don't know why he's doing that.
I think you have to click attack twice.
So it shows up on their twice.
I know it's annoying.
It's a damage critical damage.
Yes.
Okay.
All right.
The second one hits four.
18.
This guy is still is not killing.
Did I kill him?
It's not enough to kill him?
No.
Not both of them are still up.
This guy is definitely bigger though.
So that I'm going to use my action surge.
And I'm going to hit the one that looks like he's about to die.
Why can't I find my...
Where's that at?
I just had it.
Okay.
Usability.
And then skill it.
Wait.
Hold on.
That's just using my normal skill.
Where's my special skill?
Where is your special skill?
Let me skill it.
Oh, it's probably not in your hybrid form.
Probably just in the normal.
Let me drag that in from there.
Roman lost his skill.
I mean, technically.
Or...
I'll have to figure this out at one point.
I keep forgetting that your sheets are messed up.
There we go.
You should have it now.
You know what?
For that third attack?
I'm not going to use the skillet.
I'm going to try to pick up the weaker one and...
You want get into the other one.
Alright.
Grab him.
Yep.
That's a straight...
Now, would that be with advantage since I'm raging or no?
Oh, reckless.
It's a melee.
Yeah.
Go ahead.
Hmm.
How much should I roll?
16, 14.
Yeah, still enough.
Is that about a trick?
Yeah, it's higher.
As soon as you launch at him,
he again, like, sidesteps away.
Is that your turn?
Yeah.
Alright.
Okay, Malfa, you're turned.
So, that sniper can make a deck safe?
Alright.
Let me make a deck safe.
Thank you, Fails.
No, it's going to be...
Yeah, that fails.
Use this Legendary Resistance,
but I think he still takes have damage, right?
Well, it fails, so it takes full,
every fucking CC, so he's getting his health.
Yeah, then he still takes off.
So, that's for Malfa, 14.
Why, as... have to have a sh- there we go.
Alright, you see the lightning actually, like,
connect to someone as he, like,
runs away in the shadows.
Again, you lose him as he disappears from there.
I'm just wondering, what's your move?
It is only one ship.
I told you, it's gonna be a long one.
Uh...
I'm gonna say games.
I hear Malfa's going to marry next to me.
But actually, do I see the shades flying around somewhere?
No, no, you don't see it anymore.
Whatever that was, it has landed on the ship, but now.
On the ship?
Yes.
Whoop!
Who the fuck is Malfa's head?
I don't hear Malfa's head.
Yeah, on the burning ice.
Just look around, I guess.
Uh... the Marine is still trying to, like,
all the Marines are, like, still struggling to get
the log off of them, trying to crawl out somehow.
Uh...
What are you doing? Where are you moving?
Well, I think I have a decent view of, like, this side of the ship.
The one I met, so...
Alright, so this is the way that it's sinking from.
So this will be...
Yeah.
At this point, it will be submerged.
I'll say around this part, this part will be submerged.
So you can't really move much further, but the...
I'll help Marine, boy.
Alright, can you make a strength check?
Uh...
If it fails, yeah, that sucks for him.
Well, we're here fighting out this, trying to help.
That's wrong.
22.
As soon as you grab the one end of the log and you try to lift,
uh...
Initially, the weight of the log is too much,
but soon you feel like the weight is getting lighter and lighter.
As you, like, look across on the other side here,
you see your sister for a long time.
Uh, let me...
Uh, if I can go to the Marine, straight in his eyes,
and just say...
Get out of here.
Yeah, as both of you grab the log and just throw it off,
uh, you look at the Marine and just scare him off,
as he grabs his friend out here,
and, uh, again, tries to swim their way over to the other ship.
Let's look at this, bruh.
Okay. Oh my god, come on.
We're on each other now.
You, uh, as Alice sees you,
she just runs straight to you as it jumps,
because she's, like, uh, definitely smaller than you.
She jumps and kinda hugs you.
She, um, sees you in this form,
but she still recognizes that it is you.
Uh, she goes,
"I...
I don't believe it, you...
I don't believe it."
Uh, let's get out of here first.
She kinda looks around and she goes,
"I...
I didn't mean to do this. I just wanted to help him."
That's fine.
It's fine.
Let's get out of here.
I still don't know where he is.
We need to save him.
He helped me, brother.
Yes.
We're on it.
Okay.
Uh, she goes towards this Marine 2 and 3,
he tries to pull him out.
Yeah.
Uh, she's about...
Okay.
But this?
No.
Uh, okay.
Is that your turn, right?
That's your probably turn.
Yeah, that's me.
Number one.
Uh, all right.
The captain.
At this point, looks down at his soldiers,
just getting killed, left and right.
He stands on top of this mast right here,
and he will start talking to you in the center.
As he raises this word towards you,
he goes, "Beret, this will be your last warning.
Leave before you meet your unfortunate end."
By the order of G9, I, Commander Leon,
ask you, "Leave peacefully."
I was wondering why your moves are so familiar.
We're not leaving without drove in.
Unfortunately for you, that prisoner is set to be executed,
and it is my duty to see it through.
Very well.
This is your choice.
Uh, and he is...
I'll get back, again, two attacks with his magnolia.
25.
11, 25 hits.
Uh, 11.
Straight towards you, you will take, I think, half of this.
And half of the four, so that's also half, so that's nine, I think.
I mean, it's calculated as nine, so I'm just going to do it.
Against who?
Uh, Baptiste, and he's going to throw another.
You know what?
He's going to use his sword to just zoom in front,
and push this one out of the way.
And now you are face to face with this guy.
A guy.
Uh, this guy's dead, so I'm just going to remove the tokens that are already dead.
This guy's still alive.
Uh, this guy's in, and get rid of this.
Get rid of this.
Did you kill him or not?
I don't think you killed him, right?
You had aroma.
Uh, okay.
All right.
Next is Baptiste, your turn.
What is the state of the back of the ship with the mode of hell currently?
Well, the, the, the mass and everything is starting to burn now.
But not really that much damage because it's like, it's still like a large ship.
So it's just catching flame slowly.
So even if I quote unquote, break concentration, the fire is still going to keep spreading.
Yeah.
Okay.
Um,
I had a red potion for frenzy.
Blue first bead.
Black is untested.
He said, black should stay away from.
Oh, no, it's Baptiste.
We have an off the deal with at the moment.
Let me just do this first.
Now you don't get that one.
This, this, this, this.
Here you go, Bob.
All right.
As you turn around and like start to inject one of the med kids into, uh, Bob is going to come back up with 9-HV.
That's a problem.
I'm maneuver.
I'm dropping concentration.
So it won't do the like.
It's fine.
I'm just removing this.
But the ship is still on fire.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It will not head.
It will head.
Let's go.
Oh, that was so close doing that.
All right, wait, just a match.
Give it to me.
All right, what's the save content?
I'm not going to get the save content.
So, maybe I'm not okay.
That didn't work.
Okay.
So essentially, uh, what happens?
He jumps straight to you in like a millisecond.
In the meantime, you were like stabbing the, uh, med kid into, uh, Bob's leg.
At you, you turn around and start to hit him once.
He ducks on the other hit from your actual arms.
You just smashed straight through his chest and he will take the 22 damage.
Uh, no, not 17 damage.
He ought to took that, I think.
No, 22.
No, 72.
Uh, next right after this, he is going to use his fist as armorman,
hockey covers his whole fist.
He's going to do.
He's going to cost fist up your house.
Yeah.
Uh, 16th hit.
25 hits.
Uh, it's piercing damage.
Heart will be halved.
There we go.
And with the last one, he will swing from that sword.
16 hits.
He's going to use his fist again.
So he tries to punch you once.
Again, he can't grab the, your void form.
The second punch kind of reverberates and hits you.
The third slash misses.
And it's going to be his legendary action.
And Jack.
Yeah.
Uh, you said the goal was like stumbling.
Yes.
Uh, do do do.
Like, can I move?
I, because I won't rule it.
That's why.
Uh, yeah, try to catch him or at least kind of stable.
Okay.
Okay, you tried to go and check him out.
And you see like inside of his mask,
uh, there seems to be like blood dripping down from his mouth.
As he just like puts his hands towards him, he goes,
it's fine.
It happens from time to time.
Just deal with him.
I'm going to shoot the guy next to him, I guess.
Yeah, he's like.
24.
All right.
19.
Oh my god, dude.
Uh, okay.
Another one.
All right.
19.
I'm in the same condition I was when we fought the clowns.
All right.
As you walk closer, the guy's like raising his repair to slash.
Guru, you just flip around your boat piston and boom, boom straight
through his head.
The second bullet probably wasn't worth it, but you know,
it just went straight in.
Well, ever was the word that I wrote that shot.
I'm just saying it for flavor.
It would need the second one.
So he did.
Yes.
All right.
You're gonna do heroic and stand here.
This one is going to look at the captain and the guy just looks
back and goes, go save yourself.
Find any marine you can and run away.
I will handle these pirates.
So so if you leave the five feet, certain pops.
Yes, you can kill him.
Your saber-toothed Bob.
I don't think it's a favor to the back.
No, I think he was here.
I just moved him.
He was in the range.
He was he was only supposed to sidestep.
Oh, yeah, that's killing him.
All right.
Oh, oh, God.
Oh, God.
21.
Yeah.
I do want to kill him.
Do I want to knock him out?
Oh, hell yeah.
No, I'm killing his ass.
Like, Rome was beast mode.
Yeah.
Come on now.
All right.
So you just smash his head in with the skillet as he's trying to
go away.
At the soon as you do that, the guy looks at you and he is just
going to go ham.
It's his turn.
Legendary action.
Okay.
Say less.
I mean, we shouldn't have like you.
He was a pretty nice guy.
Are we killing everybody though?
I don't know.
Metal you pirates are made off.
This is the end for you now.
I'm not going to say that.
Can you make a Dexavia?
I didn't mean to do that.
We could save.
19.
Oh.
21.
I thought he would be gold brother, but he doesn't look
that much like him.
Yeah.
Nine.
He's not his brother.
No, it's a nine full.
And this 20 head.
Yes, 20 does it.
And it's still piercing so it will still have seven and nine.
Fly.
What is that 15?
You took me out my 10th health finally.
Hey.
That's going to be his action.
He's distracted by you.
Next is the sniper and he's going to attack.
Again, pop his sniper spations.
And then multi attack.
And there we go.
There we go.
13 and 24.
It will hit Alice.
You know, some of them.
No way.
It's the moment you meet her right?
Let me see with these sniper spations.
I get 2d 10 more damage.
So I'm going to roll a 2d 10.
A bigger question.
Is she a monk where she can deflect bullets?
She can.
Nice.
19 and 6.
This is not how to throw down.
What's the role for that?
It's one 10 plus level plus more level.
10 plus level plus.
Level plus.
She has another first one.
But the shot we've does impact her.
And she takes six.
10 plus four.
She's a monk.
Next is Bob.
Bob.
He's not looking at that.
You got any more of those medkits with you?
No.
I have.
So you need medkits you say.
You're going to have to eat my yachts.
What?
What does he say?
Do I do I DM?
He's lying right?
What's your passive inside?
It's probably not going to be very.
Yeah, you see it.
He's definitely lying.
He's lying.
I should be out of my hybrid form.
I don't know how to go back.
Why?
No, no, no, no, no.
It goes up to full HP.
See.
He's getting fucked up then.
Bob, you should be lucky I got you back up.
Yes, I am lucky and I did say thank you.
There we go.
20.
And then after he is, oh, he is going to do with his bonus action.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Okay, another one.
Yeah, Laveron.
He is going to turn from strength mode to survival mode.
So, Bob, he can't turn that on and turn.
He's no longer strong, but he is.
He is survival and that's his action and bonus action.
And then he's going to go raise your max pool.
But not your HP.
You do level three.
Are you sure it's not HP?
No, you, I don't know if it is.
I'm asking you.
No, like, like, when the count increases,
the HP decreases with it.
And when it increases, the HP increases with it.
How much do I need to increase then?
Five, five.
Five again.
30.
And then he's going to look at Gromand say, dude,
you do know we need to, like, not kill this guy.
But since we are at it, he's going to snap,
look at the saber-two tiger and snap and point at this guy
and the saber-two would, like, do a grin or something.
And he's going to take a few step backs, get ready to pound.
Then, like, run 20 feet.
That was 40.
Not me.
Why?
Yeah, I see what Baptiste was struggling with.
Yeah, sorry.
I see what Kakashi was struggling with.
Yeah, this guy, why are we both serving the same?
Okay, just, just, where do you want to move him?
Just tell me.
Into him?
The saber-two.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Right next turn.
Oh, it was like, you're struggling.
You're struggling away.
And there we go.
This guy is actually very big, or to do this stuff.
Normal, just normal.
There's nothing.
That's 13 that doesn't hit.
And there's guys just there.
End of turn.
I'm seeing a pattern at this point.
I don't know how you will bring the saber-two back,
but that's your decision, man.
I don't know.
Where he's going?
Gauru is going to look at you, Jack, and he goes,
"All right, help them.
Take him down.
Just make sure you don't kill him.
I'm going to be fine."
Get out of here.
It just, I need to catch my breath.
I think I will exert myself.
All right, that's just, he's going to rest for a while,
and maybe he'll join in.
Maybe he won't.
All right, no, my dear Jack.
What did all of the, who would take?
Roma.
[laughs]
You know.
What does this do?
I don't know.
Ancient savagery.
I'm not doing that.
All right, so I'm swinging with the frying pan.
We're going to go third.
I'm going to look to see if he goes down, like knockout, like KO.
If he doesn't, I'm swinging the second time.
And if he doesn't, I'm going to pop frenzy
and do it a third time.
And all recklessly.
Woo!
Because...
Keep forgetting that recklessly applies.
Fuckin' just... okay, I need to do it with the next day.
For any music, well?
Forgetting, yeah.
I forgot that.
Yeah, that's me.
Poppin' my color, poppin' my color.
Levin' that's not going to hit.
Oh, 18?
Uh, 18 matches is...
No, never mind, it doesn't hit.
Like...
Okay, so then...
What the fuck does frenzy do?
Uh, one more.
Yeah, one again.
Just hit one again.
Once again.
Is it supposed to give me a thing of an exot?
Oh my god, that, none of them are hitting.
16.
Got there.
Uh, you essentially take the skillet
and at this point, he does not even like try to dodge.
The first skillet heads bang.
The second skillet head bangs.
On both of his arms.
And the third skillet just hits him right in the head.
He just looks up at you and just goes...
(Sigh)
And you start to see like the nerve on his head kind of gets so one.
He's getting angry or angry, I'm about to second.
By the way, Rowan, you won't get exasion now.
You're going to get that after you don't embrace.
Yeah, you don't need that.
I know, I'm not...
Like, for some other reason, it's already clicked.
Like, it won't unclick.
Yeah, I'm going to...
Just give me this one.
Give me one second.
There we go.
There we are.
Like, what?
All right.
All right, Malta, see you're turned.
Yes.
(Sigh)
I still saving this guy or you're running.
Oh, we'll be running.
All right.
She is still going to save the guy.
Why?
You saved the guy.
You throw away the rubble.
She grabs this guy and just sucks him at the ocean.
There we go.
Now we be running.
Let's go.
Wait, you need seconds.
She goes here.
She tries to save this guy.
I'm going to say these tumourines have made it out safely.
These marines have made it out safely.
All right, sub to you.
What do you want to do?
You can help her or you can go fight that guy.
I'm fucking first over on the lightning, dude.
Thanks, here, please.
Yeah, I just snipered, dude.
Thanks, save.
It succeeds.
Yeah, still pick out damage.
Yeah, we're all out damage.
What the fuck?
Is this...
There is...
And the mouth is special.
All right.
There we go.
So I'm assuming you're still helping her.
Get all the rest of the marines of the ship.
How many rounds has it been?
Let me check.
Around five.
Nice.
It's Captain Leon's turn.
He is looking at you, Roma.
And he is...
Going to...
Just fucking punch you.
With advantage, sorry, I forgot.
I think it doesn't matter.
Oh, that's it.
Yeah, that's it.
I'm just going to do it.
Oh, goddammit.
I keep doing the same thing.
Okay, it doesn't matter.
It hits.
It's that and...
Tag advantage.
At 20...
Damage critical.
That's going to be...
Plus...
Seven to this one too, because you will like two ones to you this man.
Seven 24/2 is 12.
12 plus eight.
20.
Yeah, there we go.
He just raises his fist and just starts going ham on your...
Heavy body.
And the last one just connects and just...
Shred through you.
And that's going to be his turn.
Baptiste, your turn.
Oh, no, mom.
I want to have fun.
I'm not stopping you.
It's like why are you asking me for permission?
I'm not.
I gave you shit to do shit with.
He's asking himself for permission.
I see.
I'm on one HP...
Bro.
You survived that before.
I mean, I did, but this is a completely different situation.
I don't know why that's...
Then if I go down, I'll have to activate all my stuff again.
Wait a second.
You're on one.
I told you you were like on 20 or something.
He's literally on the way to the HP again.
I said I'm in two things to do.
I'm going to have to be on five.
Yeah.
You don't have medkits, right?
Yes, I do.
Yeah, but he wants to have fun.
I don't know.
I don't want to play the game.
He wants to play the game.
No, okay.
You're going to make terrible decisions now.
Or maybe he is scared and now he is going to take it.
Well, let's up to the interpretation of the player, right?
Uh-huh.
So, a judgment called, brother?
I am reaching into my bag.
Okay, which one?
And you're bringing it out?
His middle finger.
I am grabbing the black bile.
Oh, my God.
I'm drinking water.
Don't make it spit out the water.
All right.
Um, teased.
Can you give me a wisdom save for police?
He said he's taking that.
He did not say he used it.
Okay.
Sure.
You have to use it.
You have time.
Take a deep breath and rethink your decision.
All right.
I really hope you wouldn't do it, but okay.
All right, that piece.
I'm going to ask you to make an rack or corner check, which is, you know, just the bare minimum to see if a gear resist or not.
Wait, if a gear resist?
Yes.
Oh, no.
It is affecting you, mine and body.
So it is also going to affect a gear.
Go ahead.
All right.
As soon as it's about the, the, the, as soon as you inject it into your body, you start to feel the thing coursing down your veins as like your body expands.
Bit by bit.
You start to become a bit heavier.
Your body feels like it's going to sink into the floor.
And you start to see yourself getting taller and taller.
At least, can you move all your wisdom stats into strength?
Oh, fuck.
So just switch them out.
Wisdom will be 10 and strength would be 17.
Oh, no.
Why you do this to us, but these.
Don't worry.
Why you hate me?
It has an upside kind of.
Residant.
It does.
I'm going to tell that one's about to use his changed.
Well, the upside this gave about his heart attack.
I will.
You are.
What are you?
You are not here.
What's the size?
Give me a second.
I'm getting a call.
All right.
It's fine.
I'm just you are now not a medium creature.
You are a large creature.
Okay.
But you got any more of that.
Good times to give it to you before, but you didn't want it.
All right.
You're sensitive.
Like double the size of everyone on the map.
Also, as your body is growing larger and larger,
you hear your wings sprout back again.
Finally.
All right.
That's your bonus action.
What do you want to do now?
Fly away.
Fuck him up.
I'm not going to say anything.
Well, it doesn't really change much.
The fact that I.
If anything that was actually bad for me.
Yeah, it's supposed to be bad for you, man.
What do you think I've made the wisdom say for?
Was the wisdom safe to resist it?
Yes.
Well.
It would have had a different effect in case you saved the wisdom safe.
Does my is it too late to ring my bell?
Bragnet.
You can bring the ring the bell.
You can do the wisdom save again.
The switch my stats back really quick to me to.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think it's just plus three.
Just do one D 20 plus three is fine.
All right, as your body starts to get bigger and bigger,
but as soon as your wings come back,
the flames ignite in your back as your body just zoom all like all collapses.
And you feel really integrated.
Can you increase your con to 20 and think?
Yeah, that's what I was.
Con to 20 and roll 40 and 19 back to your HP plus the con,
which would be what was your con originally?
14, I want to say.
14 to that.
Don't change anything yet.
If I do that, yeah, it was 14 or so.
So six plus 19 that's 24 back to your HP.
All right, come back.
We fixed the mouth.
He was the bell.
He is the bell to re-roll the wisdom saving.
Let's go.
All right, mouth says your body condenses back to its original form with your wings back.
Sorry, not mouth is about to use with your wings back and your power.
And your body feel reinvigorated again.
You are a do fight once again.
Your back back.
That's fucking gold.
Constitution is the point.
I want to crack my knuckles.
Let's do bitch.
They don't fuck them now.
I'm not gonna miss this.
This is bound to happen.
Yeah.
Don't worry.
Mrs.
Roman, can I borrow your crate?
23 hits.
17.
That's my action and extra attack in the bonus action was drinking the potion.
All right.
You have also used your reaction for this round by the way.
Reaction.
Yeah, drink it.
All right.
Right after Baptiste chern, he is still single highly focused on Roma.
And he will just start pummeling down his attacks more and more.
I'm so glad I remembered I had a bell.
You would have been so fucked over because of the fucking wisdom nerve, bro.
It's where to go.
20 hits.
I can one hit.
Damage.
First one.
Eight.
Which will, oh yeah, that's half to eat anyway.
All right.
He's still like a single just focusing on you because you killed the guy.
Next is.
Oh, where's the guy looking?
Why does he is looking fine, but he said.
Move in.
It's like I've used the same name, but he uses like his punch instead of like his finger to encapsulate.
I'll care.
Yeah.
Yeah, I'm just gonna shoot that one Marine then.
Is he still alive?
No, he's dead.
Sorry.
Yeah.
I'm just gonna sit real.
Then there's no one else.
You got to shoot the captain now.
You know, this is.
You just got to shoot.
Yeah.
You don't have to shoot to kill.
Hey.
No.
Let's go.
I have so much fun.
I have a question.
How wise.
How wise was.
He's a critical role with a person who rolls over the net one.
Was it really wise?
Hey, hey, hey, hey.
Absolutely.
It's a one and four shot.
He shoots your horse.
Yeah.
Well,
I wouldn't have been so bad if there wasn't other enemy presence.
Then it could have been better.
Yeah.
Then I could ricochet, but all right.
And one four.
Yes.
One before.
So it's Bob,
Saber Tooth,
that is Roma.
Yes.
I might be the best option to get hit.
Probably.
Wait, no.
No, he uses his reaction.
It's Roma.
That's also five.
That sounds when he's waiting.
Wait, is it like everyone is with range?
He's raging.
See?
It's minute.
Oh, no, just said.
What?
Nine damage.
It is nine, yeah.
All right.
Roma, you get hit by Jack's bullet.
I get hit by Jack's bullet.
Yes.
Okay.
You're just two.
And he's no joke.
And now you do another net one.
Imagine.
Say that.
Right.
Matt 20, not Matt 20, but Chris.
Yeah.
So it all normal damage.
No, no.
No quick damage.
Yeah.
I think you.
Oh, normal plus the die, right?
17 plus eight.
So that's through the eight plus 16.
16.
So that's double the die.
Yeah, it's a 33 day.
Yeah.
33.
As a second bullet, like goes straight through one of his legs, you will take 33 damage.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
It's easier for me to apply his damage.
So I'm just going to do that.
There we go.
That's me.
That's you.
And.
Next is the marine over there.
Wait, two seconds.
There's something else.
Oh,
show and show.
Give me seconds.
Why isn't all on the show?
I got something else on grids.
Yeah.
We have.
I forgot about that.
Just playing chess.
When you score a critical hit against a larger and a smaller creature or smaller creature, can
it not be on the same rate?
He's always the same.
That's just an awesome thing.
But it's like a bullet.
So it's like.
The projectile lodges itself in the target for one minute using the target's replaces one of the attacks with dislodging the projectile.
The projectile speed is halfed and it's disadvantage on attack rolls.
Nice.
Yeah, he has a bullet.
It's like now.
All right.
Next is the guy and he will still bring you to shoot.
Let me stop.
One of you.
One is Alice.
Two is two.
You know this.
One is Alice.
Alice is marked.
She will take twice the damage.
No, sorry.
Extra 2d6 damage.
If she gets hit.
Which is, you know, she's not wearing a lot of armor.
Oh, fuck off.
Yeah, it's hard to come by.
I hit you, man.
I didn't roll the net 20, bro.
Dude, get your sister out of there, man.
We don't wear armor.
Yeah, but so fucking.
13, and then I think what was the roll for 2d6, and then that's doubled.
And then, oh, my God, 6 plus 12 plus 18 plus 20.
52, damn.
56.
I have damage because it's piercing.
There we go.
And can't she do the catching thing?
Well, she can.
What was the natural I made?
It's 110 plus level plus.
Yeah, it's 112 plus 15, right?
Yes, I think.
19, so I'm going to plus 19 on this.
All right, she starts to stop the bullet, but it goes through one of her shoulders.
It's going to be his turn.
Bob, Bobby boy.
Bobby, oh boy.
Bobby.
Oh boy.
Not this again.
Boom.
I literally have everything gone.
So just.
So what are the draven lines up to right now?
It's been five rounds.
So there has been an update you will find out soon.
It's not the ship.
I told you it's the middle ship.
It's always the middle ship.
We couldn't reach it.
Yeah, you don't know if it's the middle ship either.
Is the ship that's burning?
No, you don't know that either.
You're just going to get the ship.
What is it?
Why is it zero?
Why is the other thing zero?
1D20+0.
Because it's strength is zero right now.
Oh, yeah.
It's all on concentration.
OK, 20 hits.
20.
And then the damage.
Normal damage.
And then he's just going to say, hey, dude, don't take this personally.
Do the very humble.
That's just an eight damage.
Very tiny.
The first hit, the first hit of the outboard, he blocks it with armament.
And he takes one damage for that.
For the second hit, as soon as you swing harder on the other head,
he will take the full radiant damage for eight.
Is it radius?
I don't know.
20.
Let's go.
What are the rules?
Roll normal.
You don't have to roll the other one.
And then I'll add the max roll for the other one.
Let me do this.
Bob says 1D4.
Nice.
I don't have to.
Because I'm doing the bonus action this one.
The first two were like actual action.
This is full or not.
So that's for four, four, four, eight.
That's against that.
And also like, yeah, and the very humble.
Such as that, create.
Yeah, it's the very sad.
But fortunately, I have divine smile.
DM, why is it not showing critical damage on divine smite?
Because you didn't roll with critical damage.
It was just not showing any option for critical damage.
I'm just going to add the.
I don't know if the minds might can be critical.
It's the same damage with the weapon attack.
So it also doubles.
Okay.
That's fine.
So that's 1616 double is 32.
Again, the first hit lands on him.
But with the shockwave of the motion that you're swinging it with,
it still like slashes him.
So that will be another 32.
Okay.
It's kind of crazy like all the stars are my lining.
And this guy is just going to continue missing this guy just can't hit him.
That's the end of my turn.
At the end of your turn, he's going to.
Oh, no.
Okay.
As your last slash hits him, your blade starts to feel lighter as if it the contact of the blade's edge with the body is no more.
As your blade just slices straight through him.
As you see flames starting to rise out of his body.
You see his scars all over the body.
Burn scars are now starting to emit fire and his right eye where his burn scar is is starting to just burst with flame.
He looks around.
He goes.
I promise captain.
I will not use this until I'm ready.
Yeah, you're not ready.
I shall perform my duty.
And as soon as this flame starts to erupt, the rain stops completely.
As his body starts to just emit the fire, courses through the whole of this ship, can everyone make on the ship?
Can everyone make a deck safe?
I think I just put something together in my head that may not be entirely correct.
I feel like each captain of the G9 is based on one of the elements.
I think it's a good idea to have a deck safe.
What's it called?
Why is it always in that one?
It is a 66, but still, man.
What are you talking about?
I'll bring it up later.
It's going to be...
Can I absorb it?
Sure.
There we go.
You don't have a problem.
You didn't take any damage the whole fight.
There we go.
It failed.
The flame starts to engulf the completion of the ship at this point.
He starts to float in the air and he starts launching his fire attacks.
You were in his range.
You can take a swing at him if you want to buff as he's floating away in the sky.
You buffed his still far away.
I think I don't even have my reaction still though.
He left his range.
He did.
He already used his reaction.
It's a new turn.
It's a new round.
So, the map is also good.
No, no, no, sorry, sorry.
It's a ledger reaction.
It was just after Bob's turn.
It doesn't hit.
It's going to be Goros turn.
As Goros trying to escape the fire.
He's trying to escape the fire.
Let me minus a
yep
an
entertaining
And, there we go What are you
It's them and Kate I keep going
Kate is probably busy like keeping the ship here
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, I'm gonna go to the stable
Alright, yeah
Gather down
What is happening?
Gathering a bed and 10 2 goons
No, she just walks her hand away and she goes I did that to those people I need to go back and fix this
I need to find Robin
He saved me and I need to get him I'm not running away
There's a
Well, it is time to get agitated with and yeah, they're around it also shows it because this is my domain now
Yeah
At least get down
Look, you always do this. I'm not a child
Let me help and she's trying to fly away
You call I can help if you're dead
They're all just looking for a joke and right now
Okay, and what if they can't?
Be good
All right, what are you doing because she is going to fly away?
Oh
Don't know I love his boots I don't know it's yeah, it's your decision. Yeah, no
God you can't help on the burning ship get to the one next to it at least
You might might be on that ship too. Why'd you even bring us here?
Because we're also here for him and you can't help it through shots
Okay, I'll try to go is this away, right?
All right, I'm gonna say you usually like all of your actions to get here
Well, I
Can that's actually bonus action so that was an exit to
Then I had like fucking 200 feet or something
It's neon's turn and he is
Like but he's put it on the ship at the front right not even made all next to dudes
What
They don't know the front of the ship not like right next to the dude like
Yeah, I'm gonna move it hurt to you
He is going to flame slash
20 three of them hit
Role I guess it is this only three people right so it's just gonna hit all three
First one to the horse
And I think that's that's it for the horse man
reports
Yeah, the horse
The next one is for you Bob
17 oh no
Yep
There we go
Next one is for you Baptist
21 oh my god, why why why does he leave you alive every fucking time bro?
Just that right on the set
21 is half no seven is half so that's three
No, wait, let me check wait eight is half
Does the attack roll go for all of us it does it does he makes three three attacks he made three attacks all of them head right 20
The minimum was 20
I've zone now thank you all right, so you take half of the
That damage so I'm gonna give you five back there we go
So it's piercing and some fire I
Was this both of those
Of course oh
Yeah
Those three and eight that's 12 and then six so I'm gonna give you six back
14 there we go
Sorry, thank you for getting all right
Next is
I've teased
So I have more fun
You
Can't have more fun it's up to you
Romas currently home. Why do y'all have to be down so much
Bobby's also none this is the first time
Oh, yeah, this is first time rolling Bob is down every time Bob is down again. Oh
My god
No
There's a sort of crew members alive
Yeah, there's these two are live gurus alive and
Malfa's and Alice are also going to join apparently
Yeah, apparently
You don't know that
Move here
Da broma
That brova with what real my dead now with the healing
Oh, oh wait, I have to change target
That's my bonus action
Let's see if I can get lucky
Get lucky
I'm replacing morrow
I kid
G's by the way 20 feet above so you have to fly up out
Night net 20 nice go
Just roll normally and then max roll for your other
Of course I'd get the freaking crib do now
So that's
7 plus 8 plus 5
20 20
stunning strike
All right try to do that
I forgot to make the concept
Succeeds I see
Okay, oh, I don't trust him the freaking fail that so I'm just gonna try to get a good point. Okay, net one is anyone
Fortunately, all right
Well you
Fly up you
Yeah, I'm gonna I'm gonna fucking
I'm not gonna do that. I don't think it's very interesting
All right, you fly up you try to swing at him again in the ball of fire you can only see
His like one eye
Looking at you from inside, but one of the punches hits that open area and
Damages him what was it?
Or
Ors
Is it this not hockey infused though, right?
No
So seven and half of seven it's going to be three is 20 damage because there's a crate
Did I oh fuck forgot I generally forgot I do so 20
Half is 10 and 10 half is five
You got a double half
You know, I forgot I what did I do I think I gave him already 20
I'm rewarding some of the HB I already give him
Next is his turn
Legendary action
He is going to just below the shit up again
Dexave everyone
Wait wait
Does that mean Bob auto fails his death save yes, yes
Rome will Rome had already failed one yes, but Roma is not conscious
Why did I make a Dexave for him?
I think you succeeded right you succeeded go through succeeded Roma did you fail again? I fail yeah
Baptiste make it X save on the ship right yes
He's flying up I thought yeah, but it's in his vicinity like it's a whole sphere
Alice fails Baptiste you also fail so
Fortunately it doesn't do that much damage
25 half of 25 plus half of that no to about to mouth is mouth is you succeeded right?
No, it's actually it's 15
No, it doesn't do it. No mouth fails. It's all damage anyway
Half damage anyway, so that's 12 to mouth is
Why is it half damage what's your concept is by resistant oh shit you lucky some bitch
Baptiste you also take half of that which knocks you not out
So half yeah, it is I'm still saying which be your 2 hb Bob you failed the first is all
It's a 2 hb. Yeah, Mark one feel I'm gonna
half damage
to
Half damage to go which is essentially the same damage he did to you guys so it doesn't fucking matter anyway
And damage to Alice all right
You
Didn't do the demons to me
Oh God I mean
Not again Jack
Yes
On to his bs well apparently
Okay
I'm fucking should his men do
Imagine if you do another net one oh my god
Normal damage not speak that into existence. Yeah
So that's plus 16 again, so that's 33
No 33 half
What is that oh fuck off that's 16
I guess you should any other one
Mrs Mrs
You know for the first time I hear heard the gun sound yeah
My bed I was shooting my
She messed up in the head
This Leo still have that gun in his bed X that
But did he ever take it out?
No, he didn't but he also didn't move that much. Oh
Or take but he had that all of his attacks at disadvantage. I mean honestly
I think at the point when he transformed the bullet would have just fallen out
What do you mean boo it's
He's literally made of fire
Mark
How far is this guy it's fine. I'm marking mouth. It's fine. You can move you can move
More at the end of the ship
Here
Thank you
Do mark targets do mark targets have
Oh god, I don't even I don't even need to do
Good bye
Oh, that's not bad. Yeah, but I didn't roll for the max one
18 plus
20 plus the
6 plus 6 plus
2d6 of the extra mark damage
That's 54
You can catch that
I'm still a
reflect metal yes
Jumping down the zero
Uh, right 16 16 so
No, it's 11. I'm new in the 16. It's to add those five again for yeah
I think then
Uh, 16
So that's a bit palp first
No
That's not how the other Andy works. It's a little short in the long rest
We're all just bringing out a sleeping bag
Give me eight hours the bullet hits you
Alice just get over here again
Well look at it and see like literally your just
Arm completely shot with this big giant gaping hole and she is going to
Conqueror's hockey all right everyone in this vicinity
Make
Uh
Wait, what's this save for forgot wisdom save sorry
Is it where's democracy for god?
I'm checking the book give me one second
Father off the
Where's conquer's hockey I can't find it is it just
We have just used this
Now I'm checking on the book. I don't really I don't think this is correct. I don't think it's wisdom
Conqueror's hockey
It depends on what she's using
It's novice
novice
Overwhelming presence such a great flower on the shake it is it is it is a wisdom save okay
All right, wisdom save everyone
Do we know do I know
I thought looking again
What the hell
I'm gonna kick now try again yep
Maybe loads
What's okay you beat where you set off like got shots so because I
Make a wish you say you're going to from the world
Yeah apparently
I'm still in a penalty
I literally kicked you I don't know
Yeah, my name is so great out great house so
Uh, oh wow are we all scared of her why do
Why is a brother
Let me open
Uh wisdom save failed failed failed I'm gonna make a wisdom save for
Go all-room everyone have a backup character ready. Yeah, she's ready it already
Yeah, where did we get killed?
He fails
We did out of the world
I don't see you here still
Yeah, no, it's fucking cold look it
Okay, I'm gonna not select my restart
Okay, no panic
Don't panic everything is fine. Don't panic. Yeah, I lost to this baby breath. Yeah, I close the server
I'm saying I'm restarting
That's why I said
die
You didn't do this to us you did a band is us
Somebody
He's gonna he's gonna nuke everything everybody dies
Sorry, mouth, but she just got your sister, but she dies too
Yeah
Where the fuck is Linus in this fight fucking busy somewhere with the dreamers
Okay, good for you Leon's good for your dress also fails
Malfa's you're the only hold up
Uh
Yeah, I'm in
Yeah, of course you're in
For you to get back in you had to take a oh fucking paid comes over the mat
Tony
Hi
He did a lot of birds in his days
He learns how to wield it
Only against animals
Malfa smells this
Yeah
Like a business
Oh
You are the only one who succeeds
Uh other than Kate and everyone eddies will fail and go unconscious
Oh my god, what the hell
Uh, give me a second my headphones disconnected
Give me a second I'll be out back
You
All right, I'm back
Uh, all right this guy is going on
Conchies
This guy who you can finally oh, sorry, oh, you can oh my god
You can finally see
goes and conscious
The zim goes unconscious
And all of you all also go unconscious except for you Malfa's
And uh, Kate
You
What
Yes
Is a mad lad
I think he's just out of the range
Yeah
All right, uh
So I'm just gonna skip to the part where uh you all come alive except for the part that I'm gonna do with Malfa's right now
Uh, all right, Malfa's you see the guy that was like burning with flame kind of the flame
subsiding as he starts dropping straight to
the ship
And falls unconscious all of these people just thud to the ground
He touched through the ground
Baptiste also drops 20 feet down
On top of I'm sure sure he won't do that yet
Uh, all right
And
Everyone else is just taking a nap
um
You see a lot of the Marines from the backline
start to run and grab this one and drag him away
As this ship
starts to turn around
And start to leave
Uh around the same time you see a pipe show up from the bottom
And uh, you see
Dravos and Linus come through that pipe
And they have one more body with them
I mean it's not
Whatever it is it's like the the um, face is like covered in uh
A rag or something
So you don't know
Right now uh, they line as just says it's time we need to leave
Here come dropping uh, and he like creates a pipe so you can just drop everyone in
Uh, Alice carries a few of them and just drop them in
The pipe
They push the fucking saber to it somehow
Uh, I don't know if you are
It's up to Malfa's at this point. He's the only one who can make that decision
Yeah
Have you chuck everyone in the water as uh, you leave the captain behind right
No, sorry, no, no, in the pipe. Sorry. You don't kill them
Yeah, actually you in the water
All right, uh
As the pipe
Manifest on in the air all of your bodies just drop down on your ship as cade like
Navigates the ship out of the turbulent waters
You know what I really thought the fight was gonna last longer
But it's good that we got it done in one
Yeah
All right, I'm gonna turn off the music. There we go
I'm gonna move everyone back to normal waters
Uh, so I'll say about like
20 uh or so minutes pass as you all
Uh, come back to consciousness as Linus is starting to heal you one by one
Uh, unfortunately did they dish this able to sorry about
Hmm
Uh, I'm gonna bring back
Where is he
Yeah Alice and
Who else do we have? I don't think we need anyone else except for drogan, right
I don't have a token for him yet
Okay, uh, Drowbenders probably taken in uh somewhere with
Draivos and they're kind of talking catching up kind of uh while he treats to everyone's wounds
Uh, Roma, you're awake
You're awake, Bob
Uh, Baptiste, you're awake
Uh, you see uh
Jack is just hanging out in the corner
He does not want any treatment from this guy
um
And he's taking care of uh, uh, go right now
All right
The roofing's fine
You
Now this I'm gonna explain now
Oh, yeah, yeah, sorry, sorry, but okay
Yeah
All right
Make a contested role of sure and let me pick
Which
Uh, okay there we go
Sure
, okay
Uh 18
Uh, Dex you fail, okay, Roma chugged
Right
Uh, click on wrong long rest
That's it
Yeah, yeah, yeah, full wrong rest, take a full rest
Eh
No need to lose your head man
Hmm
All right
Uh
Yeah, you do see it
Yeah, I think Roma that was the last of it
Unfortunately
- Ah, huff!
- Covering your island with a bunch of kittens.
- Yeah.
Okay, roll for the health.
Yeah, I think it's just by default just five.
All right, you're seven and another seven, right?
Another five, that's 12, there we go.
(laughing)
- Yeah.
- All right.
- You're the bar vault.
- What the fuck?
Why are you dying, Malthus?
Oh, because you transform back, I say.
I say, I say, I say.
Roll for damage.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh my god, he couldn't kill him.
All right.
As he lights a fire on your ass,
you realize that you have for now.
And Baptiste, you also realize that,
oh, by the way, move your stats back to 14, right?
You have your Wings back.
No, that's not permanent.
None of the effects are permanent.
It's just varies on time, but none of them are permanent.
I want it pretty OP to just get like fucking five points
in constitution, bro.
That's crazy.
Six points, not even five.
Yeah, I see.
All right.
I mean, honestly, I don't think
it could have survived the whole thing
because literally, Alice and Malthus just made it there
in time to save everyone, I guess.
Yeah.
Oh, you know, it happened.
And now we're all safe in that gray.
Yeah, yeah, true.
True.
To be fair, it was darkness for once,
but I think the other time you did kill Roma in full sight.
This is it.
All right.
Oh my god, he's he's gung.
How do I show like full portrait?
How do I show it?
I don't know.
Is it this?
I'll post it in character at one point.
I can't show it right now.
For some reason, I can't show it right now.
I'll just share my screen.
[LAUGHS]
How bad.
I'd have to find it and then copy it.
Yeah, just post it in character.
I'm going to remember you have the time.
OK.
As everyone's waking up, what are each of you doing?
I mean, do you just want to skip time?
I'm asking, what are you doing?
Yeah, it's fine.
OK.
You enter the broom with driven and drabos.
You open the door.
You see drabos like trying to talk about something to driven.
Drovein just looks up at you.
And he's just going to just run up to you and just hit you.
26.
Oh, oh, is it?
1 plus this strength modifier, right?
I think so.
OK, 4.
He kind of punches you and throws you on the ground.
This was not your choice.
You put-- no, putting my brother's life on the line.
I was very clear, Ved Mira and Ved the old man
that I never wanted him involved.
Drabos kind of puts his hand on driven children.
Just calm down.
[AUDIO OUT]
Baptiste, I've known you for a long time.
And you know me.
This is serious.
This is not fun and games for me, OK?
I appreciate you coming to save me,
but you didn't have to put yourself on the line or my brother.
Just get out of here and I don't want to talk to you.
All right, we're next.
Who do we want to get punched by next?
All right.
OK.
I've chosen your destination.
And real life?
OK.
Yeah, Mira's going on-- fuck you.
All right, Rama, what are you doing in the meantime?
All right.
All right, Bob.
Are you mourning your saber tooth?
What is happening?
Yeah.
No.
I mean, anyone can use the help action
to wake you off right?
I mean, I think it gives you one, right?
Help.
Yeah.
All right.
You go down-- there's the Baptiste room.
There's the room that's Malthus and everyone is acquiring.
There's that room.
There's one more room, but that's where Zim is.
So where are you going?
Oh, I guess so.
I guess so.
OK.
You can go to your room then.
Yeah, she isn't there.
I forgot.
No, no.
Linus is on deck.
She can get a blur.
All right.
You take a nap.
And I'm going to tell you to do the thing once you've done.
Take the nap.
OK.
All right.
You knock on the door.
Uh, she looks at you and goes, "How?"
Are there more?
I never thought I'd meet one of us again.
, OK.
Let's see.
It's good to meet you, Malthus.
One?
Oh, sorry.
I'm really fucking that too, sorry.
I'm multitasking.
OK, give me a fucking break.
Oh, good.
Hope.
I can tell my brother that I'm not going to be
swatted like a child anymore.
Well, it's not over.
OK.
I need to find that fucking code guy.
It needs to pay for everything he's done.
You haven't told him about the doctor?
The doctor will experiment on you.
What do we need?
I say it's fine.
Oh, I guess so.
Well, anyway, I think I have a lead.
And I think you should come with me.
Are you better not?
All right.
We're going to leave for the break of dawn then.
Now you can leave me to my room and go away.
Yeah, yeah, whatever.
You
I mean, you can go with why are you not going with?
I don't understand that.
Do you have any pressing matters to attend to?
No, what do you mean the three of us?
Okay.
All right.
I was kind of thinking about this, but do you want to leave with them?
These are the new characters.
It won't really make sense.
That's why I'm not trying to do it.
Yeah.
All right.
Okay.
So I guess none of you have anything else to do, right?
We can just skip to however many minutes for a short rest.
Everyone take a short rest.
Let's find them.
Just take the short rest anyway to get spirit points back.
Let's find the spine.
Nice.
All right.
Everyone done?
No.
All right.
Okay.
That one.
Nice.
Is this some stank meal?
You have a send away is not great.
Okay.
Right around this time you start to hear siren going off at the top of the deck.
Just like, we we we we we we.
No.
All right.
Oh God.
No, no, it's not the car.
Okay.
Whoever's on deck can clearly see this like a small like drone type of object with like a small
eye pointing downwards and kind of like rotating around looking at each and every one of you.
As soon as you and Alice show up on top, Melphus, it will lock in and the voice starts to come
off from that small drone.
Well, well, well.
Look who it is.
My dear subjects finally reunited.
I am glad to see you safe again.
Now, don't be a stranger.
Come back to your friend and tone.
All right.
You start to shoot the firebolt as like the small drone thing kind of moves and like zips away on another
point like it's just moving like blink.
So from here to here here here here here it keeps moving.
Now is that a way to treat your old friend?
The eye is locked onto them.
All right.
Again, it's just as soon as you get close to it, it just zips to another location.
It's teleporting.
For you, it seems like it's teleporting.
And soon, you start to see like these myths start of kind of start to swirl up all around
the ship as the visibility gets lower and lower.
You can't even see each other anymore.
Time for farewells will be soon enough for now.
I need my subjects back.
And of course, our straggler marina.
As soon as like the mistar to coil and turn around in this area,
none of you have any visibility on anyone.
And the mistar to settle down in like the next two to three minutes.
And Alice and Malfa's are gone.
Yes.
Baptiste, you run downstairs to check on Voro.
And you see by the side of the place that Voro was on,
the whole chunk of that side is just missing.
And Voro's gone along with whatever he was tied in with.
It's not like someone tried to like take him out of the cuffs or anything,
just yank them, whatever it was.
No, my lover.
He's gone forever.
All right.
You come outside and you can see Linus is like visible is shaken.
It was him.
I don't know why he's calling himself Anton,
but I would not forget that voice ever.
It's Nikolai, his happy as father, my old teacher.
And he seems to have some sort of control over the mist now.
I don't understand why he would name himself Anton,
but I suppose he was under the protection of the Marines for a while,
while he was taking care of Sapria.
And he did disappear two years before Sapria joined the crew.
That fits the timeline.
Right on this time, you also see Drowbin come up to you
and he goes, "It's the same mist that took the old man and my captain."
So they were behind him after all.
They were behind everything.
Why?
I know where Nikolai's house was.
I went there to check for any cures for Sapria.
Maybe I can find some more things there.
Some way to track him.
All right.
Yeah, if anything important happens, we'll let you know for the next session.
I'm also kind of wrapping up.
We'll just continue in the next session.
Sure.
It's not going to be anything major.
I'm just going to keep it to the conversation.
Yeah.
All right.
Okay.
Do we want to continue or do we want to just move on?
Do we ask?
It's a north of East Blue, a small town, north.
The MIR, then when she starts running.
I don't want to do this.
The MIR, then we'll show you.
All right.
The Jojos to be continued.
Okay.
Good session, guys.
The Session.
Malthus and Alice will return near the end of the campaign.
Yeah.
Probably, probably in the newspapers.
Did you hear anything about Black Hand in the newspapers?
Other than that he's gone.
Yeah, I think not.
Yeah.
What?
You just heard that Black Hand's fleets have been missing.
That's it.
What?
Oh, the puzzle box.
I would say like everything you had on your body other than like your inventory.
Your inventory stuff would be probably somewhere in your room.
Yeah.
Just the puzzle box, I guess.
What?
Sorry.
Yeah.
Zim has like enough intelligence to solve it.
Try to solve it at least.
Also, the soda's so this fucking line is fine.
Yeah.
I think I can do that.
Fully?
What?
I think keep it a jack for now.
Oh my god.
I mean, I still think there's better options other than paid.
I mean, I feel like Zim is going to not be happy about that decision.
But all right.
I mean, I don't know.
Maybe she does.
She hasn't even decided she's going to stay with you.
So it's fine.
It's fine.
Let's move on.
Nice.
Is the prisoner here too?
Yeah.
Yeah, you do.
You do need to have a word with her.
You also need to have a word with the...
No, what's her name?
Yeah.
Yeah, you're lost.
You're going to find out what's happening on the call and then the decisions are going to be made.
Yes.
That was it.
Oh, the Klein mission, the Klein mission.
You have to find Klein.
Yeah.
Asked you if you wanted to go find Klein instead or not.
Sorry about it.
Yeah.
The six folds are in the South Blue where Klein was last seen two months ago.
She's in the South too.
I mean, do you want to find Malifice?
What in game?
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, the priorities are going to be set straight by the death of your worry about that.
No.
It's worse.
I don't think it matters as long as you, you know.
Yeah.
No.